Doba vystoupení čtyři minuty.
Máte slovo.
Dobrý den, vážený pane primátore, vážení členové zastupitelstva města Zlína.
Dříve, než jsem na minulém jednání zastupitelstva znesl svoji přípomínku k nelogickému zákazu přepravy elektrokol ve Zlínské MHD,
uvažoval jsem o tom, že tuhle věc vyřeším s ředitelem dopravní společnosti, panem Mířem Kocháněm,
s níž se znám přes 20 let a měl jsem s ní vždy korektní a snad i přátelský vztah,
který doufám i do budoucna zůstane nezměněn.
Jenže jsem si uvědomil, že 20 let té ředitelování dopravní společnosti i do jisté míry muselo v profesně i myšlenkově ovlivnit,
a proto jsem raději předstoupil před vás jako nezávislé a objektivní arbitry.
A odpověď mi přišla. Hádejte odkud?
Z dopravní společnosti podepsaná panem Mířem Kocháněm.
Úsměvné a snad i trochu alibistické odvedení města.
Takže je myslím logické, že ta odpověď byla zcela účelová a bylo v ní spousta polopravd,
nechci říkat přímo nepravd, ale abych se o ně s vámi podělil,
na to mi v mých čtyřech minutách nedáváte žádný prostor.
Můžeme to osobně, detálně rozebrat, klídně i za přítomnosti pana ředitele.
Takže zpět k elektrokolům.
Tato byla v síti Zlínské MHD přepravována zhruba 10 let,
takže jich bylo přepraveno určitě vyšší desítky tisíc, možná stovky tisíc.
Ke kolika kolizním situacím kvůli ním došlo?
Odpověď je prostá. Nula.
Můžete namítnout, že v nějakém jiném městě k problému došlo,
jenže tuto námitku já neberu. Proč?
Každoročně čtu, že někde ve světě spadlo letadlo a na zemi zabilo x lidí.
Máme se snad této smrti permanentně obávat?
Před asi třemi lety couvající dodávka v centru Zlína srazila a usmrtila na chodníku starší ženu.
Jsou snad vůli tomu chodníky ve Zlíně zdrojem nebezpečí?
Před dvěma týdny na okraji Zlína v ulici Podrozhlednou divoké prase napadlo a poranilo ženu.
Máme se všichni těto částen Zlína vyhýbat? Ne a ještě jednou ne.
A na závěr mého vystoupení ještě jedna prozba.
Nedovolte, aby byl podobný zákaz jako u elektrokol aplikován i na elektrické invalidní vozíky
s nesmyslným argumentem, že ohrožují svoji baterii ostatní cestující.
Odsoudili byste invalidy k tomu, že by jejich akční rádius kolem jejich bydliště byl silně omezen.
My, majitelé elektrokol, které svým zákazem také podobně nespravedlivě omezujete
a mnozí z nás po fyzické stránce se těm invalidům již silně blížíme,
tuto nespravedlnost nějak vydýcháme. Ale vozíčkářů by mi bylo fakt upřímně líto.
Přeji vám všem hezký den a děkuji za pozornost.
Děkuji vám za dodržení časového limitu. Dalším vystupujícím prosím, pan Šaur.
Dobrý den. Vážený pane primátore, vážené zastupitelky, vážení zastupitelé.
Dne 24. dubna 2026 jsem prostřednictvím podatelny magistrátu města Zlín předložil
za obyvatele domu č. 861 konkrétní návrh rozšíření parkovacích ploch okolí domu,
ulici Věžové domy. Tento návrh vznikl na základě doporučení města,
aby obyvatelé vytypovali vhodné lokality. Návrh obsahuje konkrétní řešení,
situační nákres a byl zpracován s důrazem na minimalizaci zásahů
do městské zeleně. Současně byl podpořen 22 ze 29 bytových jednotek,
tedy 76 % obyvatel domu. Od podání návrhů uplynulo téměř 2 měsíce
a obyvatelé dosud neobdrželi žádnou informaci o tom, zda byl návrh posouzen,
komu byl předán, zda proběhlo místní šetření nebo jaké jsou další kroky města.
Proto bych se chtěl dnes zeptat, v jakém stavu se tento návrh nachází?
Byl již odborně posouzen? Pokud ano, s jakým výsledkem?
Pokud ne, kdy lze jeho posouzení očekávat?
Domnívám se, že pokud město vyzve občany k předložení konkrétních návrhů
a občané takový návrh zpracují a doloží podporou většiny obyvatel domu,
měli by alespoň obdržet informaci o tom, jak s jejich podmětem bylo naloženo.
Děkuji za odpověď.
Učečil pověd písemně, tak jak to máte zatrhnuté, přihlášte na vystoupení.
Děkuji. A můžete aspoň dnes občanům sdělit konkrétní termín,
dokdy bude náš návrh odborně posouzen?
To vám určitě neřeknu, protože v současné době jsou nějaké zákonné hluty,
které měly být zhruba 30 dnů, ale já vám neřeknu, v jakém je to stavu.
To znamená, já předpokládám, že vám odpověď je ve lhutě,
ale vedle toho je posuzování vůbec těch vašich návrhů.
To znamená, já vám neřeknu, jestli to bude trvat ještě 30 dnů,
nebo to bude trvat 2 měsíce, nebo jak dlouho to bude,
protože nevím, v jakém je to stavu celé otevření.
A ještě se zeptám, jaká je dlouhá doba,
nebo lhuta na zpracování prakticky toho našeho návrhu,
který byl podán toho 24. dubna 26 podatelnou na magistrát města Zlína.
Jak jsem vám teďka řekl, já předpokládám, a můžeme to prověřit,
že vám v termínu bylo odpovězeno na to, na co jste událi ten podnět,
což ale neznamená, že je na to zpracována projektová dokumentace či cokoliv dalšího.
To znamená, předpokládám, že odpověď vám došla,
ale v jakém stavu je řešení těch vašich návrhů,
tak to je věc druhá a to vám nedokážu říct.
Nepřišla mě odpověď.
Já mám před sebou odpověď ze dne 10.4.2026,
kterou vám zasílal odbor dopravy. Bylo to k vystoupení 26. března.
A dohledáme samozřejmě ještě ty další věci.
Na základě té odpovědi z 10.4. byl zpracován ten návrh,
sepsány všechny souhlasné listiny, vypracován projekt
a 24. dubna byl podán na podatelnu magistrátu.
Takže to už je vlastně...
Rozumím tomu.
Písemně vám odpovíme a zjistíme ten stav projednávané věci.
A jsou tam nějaké lhuty, když podáte něco na magistrát?
Určitě jsou.
A jaké?
S většinou na podání odreagujeme do 30 dnů.
Je to složitější záležitost do 60.
Vyžadu-li to například různé projektové práce a tak dále,
tak minimálně ta informace, že ty práce jsou zadány, by vám měla přijít.
Prověříme to a odpovíme vám.
Děkuji.
Já děkuji.
Posledním vystupujícím je pan, ještě pardon, jestli chce reagovat pan Čížek.
Takže poprosím posledního vystupujícího pana Zvoníčka.
Jenom, pane Zvoníče, chci upozornit, že to je online přenos ven,
tak nepoužívat nějaké osobní data.
Děkuji vám moc.
Děkuji.
Můj příspěvek a prozba se týká obnovení uživatelského nájmu bytu ve Zlíně,
ke kterémž nedošlo z důvodu mého velmi těžkého a komplikovaného úrazu a operace ruky,
když jsem se ocitl nesoběstačným a nesabostatným.
A také kvůli dlouhodobé diagnóze depresií, kterým tepím.
Obrátil jsem se s touto prozbou na pana radního Jiřího Robénka
a zde cituji aspoň část tohoto dopisu.
Odvolávám se proti usnesení rady města Zlína, číslo 23.9.R. 2006,
ze dne 11.05.26, kterým rada schválila neprodložení smlouvy o nájmu bytu,
číslo 626 v bytovém domě na ulici Středova,
4786, kterou jsem uzavřel statutální městen Zlín jakožto pro najímatelem.
Navrhuji uzavření prodlužující nájemní smlouvy.
V průběhu jejíž platnosti si bude moci město Zlín jakýmikoliv způsobem opakovaně ověřit,
Užívám řádně, nájem neplatím řádně a včas a veškeré povinnosti nájemní se si plním jak nejlépe mohu.
Oduvodnění. V čase mého předpokládaného pobytu v bytě a v čase předpokládaného plnění řádných povinností nájemníka,
jsem se po těžkém pracovním úrazu z ruky spojeném s komplikovanou operací,
což je doleženo lékařskými zprávami vlastně přiloženými k této žádosti,
pro své omezení v hybnosti a soběstačnosti v bytě vůbec nezdržoval a o povinnosti si neplně jak vyřádně měl.
Týkalo se to například i opožděné platby inkasa a stejně jako domluvený posun termínu výměry vodoměrů.
Přestože za uvedené skutečnosti mohl prokazatelně můj zdravotní stav a za způsobené nepříjemnosti se velmi omlouvám
a svého nekonání ve věci velmi lituji, aby se již v budoucnu jakákoliv ze zde uvedených i neuvedených chyb neopakovala.
Založil jsem si ve svých 53 letech po projezd v životě svůj bankovní účet.
Z tohoto účtu jsem provedl trvalý platební příkaz ve výši 6588 Kč měsíčně.
Trvalý příkaz jsem provedl i v příjmové kapitole účtu a to od svého zaměstnavatele.
Mám zkrácený pracovní úvazek fyzioterapeuta.
Prohlášení od paní ředitelky je přílohou i od České správy sociálního zabezpečení,
kde jsem měl celkem nevyzvednutých 11 částek.
Byl jsem rodič, ponoukal napsat prohlášení, že v jejich domě v Brumově bylnice
budu pobývat pouze o víkendových rehabilitačních návštěvách
a pod zbytek týdne se budu zdržovat ve svém pronajímaném bytu ve Zlíně,
aby došlo k mé těsnější socializaci a v městě samotném nezávisném způsobu života.
Na základě mnou doložený skutečností proto žádám Radu města Zlína o přehodnocení rozhodnutí
vedoucího usnesení, které nezohlednilo ani můj dlouhodobý natož akutní krátkodobí
přes jedno trvající zdravotní stav.
Neprodloužení nájmí smlou vypovažuji a to, přestože jsem si vědom své nedůzlednosti
a chybného nejednání nespojeného s alespoň dostatečním vysvětlení všech pokolností
za příliš tvrdého patření vůči člověku, který má řadu vážných zdravotních i život
značně tělesně, psychicky a sociálně omezujících diagnoz.
Pokorňu vás, vážení radní, proto všechny prosím i zastupitele,
abyste vše znovu zvážili a po doloženém seznámení s mojí zdravotní, psychickou, sociální situací
mě nechali v bytě bydlet.
Za vaši schový vazost, slitování se a pochopení vám děkuji. Děkuji moc.
Děkuji vám za dodržení časového limitu. Vaším případem se bude zabývat Rda na svém dalším jednání.
To je poslední vystupující k bodu vystoupení občanů a předávám zpět slovo panu primátorovi.
Moc děkuji všem občanům, kteří došli dneska na zastupitelstvo. Děkuji za jejich podněty.
Budeme pokračovat v jednání zastupitelstva. To znamená dalším bodem je schvální programu.
Včera vám byl uvolněn doplněný návrh programu o jeden materiál, takzvaně na stůl.
Jedná se o novou obecně závazné vyhlášky, ve které se upravuje pouze datum konání akce.
Všechny materiály jste obdrželi v elektronické podobě a v programu jsou čislovány tak, jak byly dodatečně zařazeny.
Znamená někdo k navrženému programu připomínky či doplňky?
Není tomu tak, prosím pojďme a slovat program tak, jak vám byl zaslán.
Pro 37. Program dnešního zasedání byl přijat.
Pokračme je tedy bodem číslo čtyři, což je zpráva o činnosti finančního výboru.
Chtěl bych se zeptat k tomu, jestli má někdo nějaké dotazy k této zprávě.
Poprosím náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Děkuji za slovo, pane primátore. Hezké ráno.
Nevím, jestli budou nějaké připomínky k práci finančního výboru, ale já si dovolím,
protože jsem čtyři roky docházel na finanční výbor s titulu hosta
a referoval jsem vlastně o věcech ekonomických, které se tam probíraly
a které jsme diskutovali, ať už k rozpočtu nebo k jednotlivým finančním operacím,
který jsme dělali, tak bych všem členům chtěl poděkovat za ty čtyři roky
té spolupráce, jak opozičním, tak koaličním, protože myslím si,
že jsme si zachovávali věcnost a používali jsme argumenty a čísla.
Myslím si, že to prostředí, které jsme pracovali, bylo opravdu konstruktivní,
tak za to chci poděkovat všem, kteří ty čtyři roky věnovali svůj čas a energii,
práci ve finančním výboru. Děkuji.
Mocka děkuji. Já se učitě připojuji k tomu poděkování,
ale já to vezmu potom globálně, předpokládám,
s posledním zastupitelstvou, které proběhne v září,
protože věřím tomu, že budeme pokračovat i nadále, ať už v komisích, tak ve výborech,
tak i na zastupitelstvu v té konstruktivní věstné debatě
bez nějakých politických přísluš, jako nějakých politických handrkování,
které samozřejmě s vidícími se volbami se vždycky hotoví zabízí,
ale stále tomu tak není. Takže za to děkuji už předem a předám na slovo panu Dudákovi.
Dobré dopoledne, dámy a pánové. Pane primátora, děkuji za slovo.
Volby se blíží, já jsem nejméně aktivní člen, tak si dovolím využít této situace,
abych také poděkoval za to, jak funguje finanční výbor,
už jsem také členým jak pan Chalánek a další kolegové.
Nicméně teď vážně, vážím si toho konstruktivního přístupu,
jakékoliv informace nám, pokud nám chybí nebo jsou požadovány,
tak nám to úřad ve výborné podobě a kvalitě
v nejkračším možném terminu předloží.
A za tuto aktivitu a práci děkuji.
Jen bych upozornil, že myslím si, že to dřív nebylo zvykem,
že nám na finanční výbor chodí podměty občanů
na nějaké konkrétní věci. Teď řešíme parkovací dům,
vedle plaveckého stadionu a také transparentnost parkovacího režimu.
My jsme finanční výbor, který kontroluje nebo dozoruje
především finance, nejsme kontrolní výbor,
tak by možná bylo dobré, kdybychom na stránkách města
lépe definovali, jaké jsou role jednotlivých orgánů
nebo výborů za tento podmět. Jenom bych se přimlouval. Děkuji.
Moc chrát děkuji za ten podmět. My jsme to samozřejmě řešili i v rámci
po tom, co ten dopis došel, protože tam bylo jmenovitě napsáno přímo,
že to má být na kontrolní i na finanční výbor. Tím pádem
i z pozice toho dopisu nemám jen možnost, než to na finanční výbor
předložit, kdy finanční výbor má tu možnost zareagovat tím,
že to není obsahem jeho náplně práce a tím pádem se tím zabývat nebude.
Ale prakticky mi zase pokud občan napíše, že to máme na ty jednotlivé orgány
předložit, tak my máme povinnost to tam předat.
Ale určitě to můžeme více zpustit vyspecifikovat na těch stránkách,
ať každý rozumí tomu, co jednotlivé komise nebo ty výbory řeší,
aby to zbytečně neposílali někam, kam to vlastně nemá smysl.
Poprosím, jestli má někdo něco dalšího výboru číslo 4.
Není tomu tak, pojďme tedy prosím hlasovat materiál číslo 4.
Pro materiál číslo 4 byl přijat, pro 39.
Tento materiál jsme brali na vědomí.
Materiál číslo 5 je závěrečný účet, to znamená,
máme tu sepsáno, jak jsme teda dopadli za rok 2025,
což jsme už ty predikce vám sdělovali,
už předem, ale poprosím se řejmě
náměstka Jirka Chalánka, aby vám uvedl tento bod.
Děkuji za slovo, pane primátore.
Já si dovolím, protože vždycky jsme o tom debatovali,
tak dáme určitě prostor v debatě,
nicméně možná na ten úvod bych řekl pár takových dat,
které považuji za důležitý, aby tedy zazněli z titulu
hospodaření roku 2025.
Čili začneme celkové přijmí 2 miliardy 864 milionů,
celkové výdaje 2 miliardy 969,
čili víc jsme konstruovali rozpočet jako přebytkový,
nakonec skončil schodkový 105 milionů.
V rámci těch 105 milionů je potřeba říct,
čím jsme ho vyrovnali.
Vyrovnali jsme ho přebytkem z minulých let,
to znamená zapojili jsme do rozpočtu peníze,
které jsme si řečeno terminologií finanční ušetřili,
z roku 2024, 2024 a 2023.
Ten celkový deficit 105 milionů
byl částečně tvořený i rozdílem na revolvingovém účtě,
to znamená, že revolvingový účet používáme pro financování dotací
a ten rok dopadl tak, že jsme více předfinancovali,
než nám na to potom jako ty dotace chodili.
Má to logiku, protože většina těch dotací je ex post,
to znamená, že nechodí průběžně, chybí po, ale chodí po zúčtování.
Takže celkový ten deficit na tom nebo rozdíl na tom účtu je 14 milionů,
takže ty teoreticky můžeme z toho trošku jako bokem,
protože oni v čase přijdou.
Čili celkový ten deficit, který potřebujeme vykrýzt z toho přebytku minulých let,
je 93 milionů.
Jedno číslo, o kterém se bavíme a které bude do budoucna hodně důležité,
to je rozpočtová odpovědnost.
V současné době podíl dluhu průměrů příjmu za poslední čtyři roky je 21%.
To znamená, že my tam 21% je ten poměr dlouhodobých závazků či příjmu za poslední čtyři roky průměru.
Takže je to číslo pro nás v tuto chvíli příznivé, ale je potřeba říct,
že zatím, byť jsme schvalovali v letošním roce, protože jsme v letošním roce schvalovali,
určitě si vzpomínáte úvěr na vykrytí ITI ve výši 1,1 miliardy, tak ten tam ještě započítaný není.
Čili to číslo bude určitě v průběhu let, už v letošním roce zapojujeme ten úvěr,
to znamená, že se bude zvyšovat, ale i tak při té částce 1,1 miliardy
nepočítáme, že bychom jaksi překročili tu hranici toho bezpečného,
těch bezpečných rozdílů mezi výšidlu a průměru příjmu za poslední čtyři roky 60%.
Těch věcí, které bych tady chtěl zmínit, je potom samozřejmě
každý rok je povinnost, aby závěrečný účet prošel auditem,
to znamená, že auditovaný zpráva o výsledku přeskoumání o spodaření je přílohou
vlastně toho závěrečnému účtu nebo nedílnou součástí toho účtu.
Já si myslím, že z titulu toho přeskoumání jsou vlastně tři důležité vyjádření auditora.
To je vyjádření k souladu hospodaření z hledisky přeskoumání hospodaření.
Potom druhá kategorie je vyjádření ohledně chyb a nedostatku.
Tam je konstatování auditora, že nezjistil žádné chyby a nedostatky.
A potom ta třetí skupina se týká upozornění na případná rizika,
čili tam je výrok auditora, že nebyla zjištěna žádná rizika.
Řekl bych, že co se týče procesného vedení toho rozpočtu a víte sami,
že těch položek za ten rok se nás čítá v různých kategoriích,
že ten fokus, čeho se ten rozpočet týká, je opravdu široký.
Tak si myslím, že to je hodnocení, které je pro nás určitě hodně dobré.
Vykazuje jakousi kvalitu nebo ukazuje kvalitu ekonomického oddělení,
které jsou ten rozpočet samozřejmě zjistka těch procesních věcí stará,
tak aby všechno bylo tak, jak má být.
Samozřejmě, jestli máme deficit nebo přebytek, to už je naše rozhodnutí.
Nicméně já bych chtěl poděkovat ekonomickému odboru a paní Holcové
speciálně za to, jak vlastně se s těmi, s tím rozpočtem pereje
a jak jsme schopni reagovat nebo jak hlavně ekonomického oddělení
a hlavně ekonomického oddělení je schopno reagovat i nějaké zákonné změny
a různé věci, které se během průběhu roku mění,
že nakonec opravdu se dá spolehnout na to,
že to bude zaučtované všechno tak, jak to má být.
Dřív to hodnocení bylo, dávalo se A, B, C,
dneska jsou tři výroky ohledně toho rozpočtu,
takže já si myslím, že dlouhodobě ekonomický odbor funguje
získat té zprávy toho rozpočtu a je na něho spoleh,
což je dobrá zpráva, když už jsme tady zmiňovali ty volby do budoucna,
že ať už ten rozpočet se stavuje a bude s ním pracovat kdokoliv,
tak se na ekonomický odbor může spolehnout a to je hodně dobrá zpráva.
Takže paní Holco, ještě jednou děkuji a zadám vám prostě z diskuzi.
Dobrá, moc děkuji za ten úvod a poprosím pana Dudáka,
který se hlásí do diskuze k tomuto bodu.
Děkuji za slovo. Z naší stranu také velké poděkování
ekonomickému odboru i tomu vedení pana Chalánka.
Otevřeně říct, že jsme v tomto volebním období v tom získali
i díky vašemu přístupu daleko větší vhled a schopnost ty věci rozlišovat a pochopit.
My za naše hnutí budeme hlasovat pro,
ale řeknu otevřeně, my schvalujeme správnost a formálnost tohoto dokumentu.
Nikoliv, že se stotužněme se všemi náklady a projekty a investičními akcemi,
které jsou samozřejmě obsahou náplně tohoto rozpočtu.
Tak to jenom pro naše příznivce musím převést na pravou míru. Děkuji.
Děkuji.
Děkuji za to poděkování.
Myslím si, že opravdu ekonomický odbor tady dlouhé roky odvádí velice dobrou práci,
což opravdu to hodnocení to potvrzuje.
Poprosím Kateřinu Francovou.
Dobré, dopoledne všem.
Za nás my se závěrečným účtem za zaučtování,
za tou technickou stránkou, s tou technickou stránkou také souhlasíme,
ale v ní máme to takové vystavení vysvědčení městu.
Vadí nám, že přesto, že se vybralo rekordní množství peněz na daních,
tak hospodaříme s jakýmsi dluhem.
Žijeme nad poměry, máme tam 113 tisíc navýšený dluh.
To, co nám dále vadí a možná i to je...
113 milionů, pardon, děkuji, děkuji.
To by bylo krásné, 113 tisíc.
Co nám vadí, tak nám, jako druhý bod nám vadí,
že běžné výdaje byly loni vyšší než příjmy města.
Tím pádem se muselo sáhnout do úspor.
A třetí bod, který vnímáme jako takový poměrně velký problém a viditelný
a tahne se delší dobu, je to otázka investičních výdajů,
protože pokud se podíváme na to, co bylo naplánované a co se skutečně
proinvestovalo, tak jenom v roce 2022 bylo proinvestováno 95%,
v roce 2023 43% pouze, v roce 2024 44% a v letošním roce, nebo v roce 25 pouze 51%.
Což nás trošku trápí, je to výsledek toho, že v podstatě se nedotahují investice,
které byly naplánované.
A to se nám jako úplně nelíbí. Tady z hlediska vystavení, vysvědčení
nejsme spokojeni, protože to svědčí o tom, že sice plány jsou hezké,
ale nezvládá se to proinvestovat. Takže s tímto my nesouhlasíme
a trápí nás tady toto.
Dobře. Prakticky se podíváte na dlouhodobý stav asi za posledních 15 let,
když si vezmete, tak co se týká proinvestovanosti, tak za doby
nebudu řešit koho, byla například 30%, 35% byla jeden rok.
Ale prakticky já se toto vůbec nechci vůbec vracet,
protože to si tady hážeme horký brambor zleva doprava a říkám,
prakticky je to ten stav, který je jako reálný.
To znamená, máte naplánovány investice.
To, že máte pro investované 50%, neznamená,
že ty investice se nezrealizují. Znamená to to,
že například ta příprava trvá něco déle a přesuní se do dalšího roku.
Takhle se to posunuje více z roku na rok a pokud neděláte projekty
ve stylu oprav chodníků, které jste schopni udělat víceméně,
nechci s obratem, ale relativně rychle a s vámi říkám o opravách lokálních,
nikoli o stavbách, tak v tu danou chvíli ty procesy prostě trvají.
To je to stejné, jako se bavíte, že velké kino nachystat trvalo 10 let.
Myslím si, že asi nikdo nečekal, že od doby zahájení výběrového řízení na soutěž,
na architekta a všechno ostatní, že to bude trvat 10 let a prostě výsledek je ten.
A výsledek prostě tady tento je, bohužel,
protože ty procesy jsou někdy další, než sami chceme.
Stejně tak povolovací proces, bohužel vnímáme všichni, co se děje v rámci povolovacích procesů,
takže za sebe si také, jako řeknu, nemyslím, že bych měl radost z toho,
že jsme někdy třeba na těch 50, 60 procentech.
Na druhou stranu je potřeba říci, že je ten stav, že ty projekty se dotahují.
Není pravdou, že by se nedotahovaly, jenom to prostě bohužel někdy trvá déle, než se čeká.
A to pak způsobí to, že samozřejmě v rámci toho přesunu z roku na rok
se ty částky prostě nenaplní tak, jak by měly.
To znamená, ve chvíli, kdy například stavba je započatá,
to znamená víceméně byly finance alokovány na celou stavbu,
stavba se vysoutěžila, podepsala se splouva a stavba probíhá,
tak vy z roku na rok potom přesunujete finanční prostředky.
Tím pádem ty finanční prostředky, které se nevyplatily tomu zhotovitelu,
protože ještě to nebylo hotové,
tak to danouky se převádí z roku na rok,
ale samozřejmě v tom účtu to potom je dáno,
že těch 50 prostě vícem to vpadá z toho původního plánu.
Takže za sebe ano, všichni bychom byli rádi,
kdyby ty věci se dali dělat rychleji,
to určitě asi bychom si přáli všichni.
Bohužel jsme prostě v systému, který nám tady zákonodáci dali,
a ty pohlovací procesy trvají, jak trvají.
Někdy máme samozřejmě problém se soutěžemi skrze různé zakázky,
že někteří dodavatelé dávají své k úhosů a podobně,
a opakujete ta výběrová řízení.
To znamená, není to ani o tom,
že když už máte stavební povolnit, že máte vyhráno,
jsou tu zakázky zcela otevřeně, které soutěžíme rok,
a ještě nemáme dodavatelé,
protože to soutěžíme více než na třikrát.
Vzhledem k tomu, že se ti dodavatelé mezi sebou různě napadají
u různých institucí.
Takže dotahování těch věcí je samozřejmě to,
co si myslím, že se tady daří.
Určitě není o tom, že bychom nedotahovali věci,
a jenom prostě bohužel ty hluty, které jsou,
a ty zákony, které jsou,
tak nám prostě dávají ty možnosti, které máme,
a já si myslím, že ty projekty, které v současné době se soutěží
nebo jsou již podepsané,
tak si myslím, že jsou jasným důkazem toho,
že ty věci se po mnoha letech,
když se bavíme desítky let o některých projektech,
tak se dotahují.
Takže tady toho...
A samozřejmě bych velice rád,
kdybychom některé věci nemuseli řešit,
aby je hotové na příkladu před 25 lety,
o kterých se tady historicky baví
a do této nejsou.
Poprosím, jestli chce reagovat,
pan náměstek?
Ještě tam byl pan Prchal,
ať nepředlíhám.
Jo, jo.
Já bych chtěl říct jednu takovou reakci
na ten...
na to vystoupení, paní financové.
Kvalita financová...
nebo řízení financí
nemá vůbec žádný...
a jejich kvalita nemá vůbec žádné vztahy na to,
jestli sestavíte rozpočet stupkový,
nebo představíte to,
to vůbec o ničem nevypovídá.
Dlouhodobě dělat přebytkový rozpočet je nesmysl,
protože potom se dostává do toho,
že generujete úspory,
možná i budete zhodnotovat jako depozita,
ale je otázka jako,
co z toho budou mít ti občané,
protože my jsme tady první občany.
To znamená jako, že když cokoliv děláte v rozpočtu,
tak se říká jako nehled na nominál,
nehled na trend a prostě nějaký časový úsek,
v kterém funguješ.
Samozřejmě, tak jak říkám,
že dlouhodobě dělat přebytkový rozpočet
není žádná výhra,
tak ono dlouhodobě dělat schodkový
taky nemůžete,
čili vy se musíte dostat někde
v tom horizontu pěti let,
někde do nějaké nuly,
kdy to vyrovnáte a začnete jít zase nějakou trajektorií.
Takže
buďme opatrní na toho hodnocení,
protože ta kvalita toho rozpočtu jde o to,
abyste maximálně využili
ty prostředky, které máte
a ty nejvíc
poblivňuje jako míra provozu.
To je klíčová věc jako pro rozpočet.
Míra provozu.
Těch provozů máte
samozřejmě nahodilé výdaje
a potom jsou jako ty trvalé.
To znamená, to jsou ty,
propíšou do tohleté doby
a samozřejmě musíte,
musíte s něma pracovat.
Takže takové ty
rychlé,
krátké zprávy,
jako co je dobře a co je špatně,
úplně jako
v tom rozpočtu
nejsou dobrý
a ještě je potřeba si uvědomit
vlastně, co ten závěrečný účet je.
To jsou finanční toky.
To jsou finanční toky,
které vlastně realizujete
v rámci
toho roku,
nebo to dodaného
fiskálního období.
A co je důležité,
jako jestli čerpáte nebo nečerpáte.
Já bych řekl tak,
to číslo je určitě,
není něco,
z čeho bychom měli obrovskou radost,
ale potom musíte říct,
co ho ovlivňuje,
protože si potom nějakou významnou akci
nakryjete a nečerpáte ji,
znažuje, kolik jste přidělili
a skutečně spotřebovali.
To znamená, když někdo vystaví fakturu
až 1.1. roku 26,
tak už to nedostanete ve roku 25
a vypadáte zase trošku jinak.
Takže já bych
opravdu prosil o to,
jako to, co jsme dělali
na finančním výboru, je potřeba si na to
vidět to trošku v tom komplexu
a pokud chceme dělat nějaké soudy,
tak opravdu jako na základě toho,
že se podívám na nějaký čtyřletý období
a řeknu, ano, tady je to blbě.
Stejně tak, jako pokud se něco
čtyři roky dělá blbě,
tak to nespravíte ten další rok.
To se bude nějaká trendová věc, kterou potřebujete
propsat do toho rozpočtu a fungovat.
Pro budoucnost a pro kohokoliv,
kdo tady bude, jako je důležitý
jako maximální věc
nebo maximální
starost věnovat té
provozní části,
jako protože tam
je
ta
kvalita toho rozpočtu a toho zpodaření.
A potom je druhá věc.
V momentě, kdy
generujete vlastně
nějakou rezervu, čili řekněme
to saldo, tak to saldo
umět použít zase v čase.
Čili nebát se
i velkých projektů,
nebáli jsme se úvěru,
prostě jsou věci, které mají přesah
čtyř let, jo, jestli spravujeme dneska
kino, tak určitě ho nespravujeme na deset let.
To jsou věci, které mají
určitý přesah a určitě je dobře si na ně půjčit,
ale musíte to umět,
nebo musíte to mít jistotu,
že když ten závazek,
ten dlouhodobý závazek třeba
dvaceti leté z platnosti propíšete
do toho salda, že na to budete mít
a neohrozíte ten provoz.
Protože vy,
to je rozdíl oproti
fungování normální obchodní korporace,
že vy nemáte šanci
na pracovat,
máte 80% příjmu generovaných,
který nemáte ve své moci,
to znamená, že vy si na té příjmové části
řekněme si zase moc nepomůžeme.
Takže je to ten balans a potom,
jako v momentě, kdy generujete to saldo,
tak přemýšlet, jako kolik těch věcí jste schopni
podstat do průběžného financování,
to znamená formou úvěru.
A tam si myslím,
že třeba
ty dlouhodobé závazky na úrovni,
ale nejpřím,
ale na úrovni salda,
můžou být třeba do výše 30-35%.
Potom vám to dává určitou možnost
si s tým rozpočtem trošku hrát.
Protože řeknu jednu takovou věc,
nikdo z nás nerozhodl o tom,
že bude 9% valorizace tarifů,
a to je 60 milionů,
které musíme propsat v příštím roce.
Ale ne v příštím roce,
v každém roce dál.
Takže pro příští volební období
máme 240 milionů,
jako které musíte zúčtovat navrhu.
A jenom pro vaši informaci,
teďka paní Holcová dělala příjmy,
my jsme počítali s tím,
že na to,
aby jsme sanovali náklad
neparagodických pracovníků,
potřebujeme 13% růst
v kategorii jedničkových daní.
Ten se neplní.
To znamená,
že vlastně,
jak si ten rozpočet,
tak jak byl podstavený,
že nám vykrije ty neparagodické pracovníky,
tak bez už tam máme nějaký deficit.
Je tam deficit třeba,
já řeknu teďka do 2 milionů,
ale jsme v půlce roku,
a to se mám všechno,
jako v tom rozpočtu,
takhle nějak to pracuje,
takže musíme být hodně opatrní
na to, co propíšeme
do toho provozního,
do těch provozních výdajů.
Takže to je jenom to.
Ale souhlasím,
51% není žádná výhra.
Moc teda děkuju,
poprosím, že ještě chtěla reagovat
spojení Francová.
Děkuju.
Jestli můžu,
já si pamatuju,
že jsme proinvestovávali 70%.
Těch 30% si fakt nejsem jistá.
Podívám se na to schválně,
protože toto mě nějak nesedí,
ale možná mám krátkou paměť.
Já jsem tady nechtěl upozorovat na někoho dál,
protože jestli se podíváte,
no to tam jeden rok takhle skočilo úplně blbě,
ale to je jedno.
To není vůbec,
to není ukazatelem,
který ve výsledku něco
jako reálně říct ukazuje.
To je prostě stav,
že řeknete dobré v tomto roce,
a teď to řeknu,
dobře jsme ty smlouvy podepsali pozdě.
To je realita třeba,
například.
Víceméně se to vyučtuje až rok později.
Pak se musíte spíš dívat,
co je a co není hotové.
Proto tady máte předkladané střednodobé plány
a další věci těch jednotlivých projektů.
A v tu danou chvíli,
to je za mě ten účet,
který se vlastně má řešit,
jestli ty věci jsou a nebo nejsou.
Jestli ta proinvestovanost vedle toho je 30%,
40%, nebo 60%, nebo 90%,
to je už otázka toho,
jak moc se to podařilo trefit do toho roku
v rámci co je přípravy těch projektů.
U těch menších to bývá o něco jednodušší.
Na druhou stranu ten poholovací proces
je stejný jak už u těch malých,
tak u těch velkých.
A pak je prostě otázkou,
že kolikrát i ty malé projekty samozřejmě
potřebují majetkoprávní přípravu
a můžeme se tam naprosto zaseknout,
že někdo nám ten pozemek nechce
nebo až později atd.
Takže za mě je potřeba si zejména hlídat,
co je a co není hotové.
A proto vám ty podklady překládáme vlastně,
co se chystá a to v těch plánech je.
A pokud se ty věci plní,
tak to je, když řeknu,
rozhodně relevantnější ukazatel,
než pro investovanost,
která se i v průběhu roku samozřejmě mění
v rámci upravených rozpočtů.
Prosím ještě paní Francovou.
Jenom poslední.
My jsme na to využívali tenkrát ty přísliby
finanční z roku na rok.
Myslím si, že jsem si úplně nevšimla,
že to využíváte tak, aby...
Víš Mirku, o čem mluvím?
Vím, o čem se bavíme.
Rozložili jsme investice tak,
že jsme vlastně dávali příslib tak,
aby nám to nezasahovalo,
ty větší projekty,
jako kdyby do té neproinvestovanosti,
když to řeknu.
To pokračuje dál, jenom místo příslibů
to děláme formou, že vlastně v těch tabulkách,
uvolňujeme, že tam máte přímo napsáno,
co v dalších letech bude.
To znamená, není třeba dle současné legislativy
dle toho, co jsme zjištěli,
to řešit jako přímo příslibama,
ale je potřeba to vlastně mít uvedené
v těch materiálech, aby s tím zastupitelstvo
jako tu informaci mělo.
A na základě toho se to následně propisuje.
To znamená, není potřeba to jakoby předskvalovat
příslibama, tak se to řešilo dřív.
Stačí to tady tím uvedením té informace
v materiálech a tím se to následně propisuje,
aby to bylo ve středědobém plánu financování.
Poprosím ještě náměstka Mirka Chalánka,
co chtěl upřesnit.
Nevím, pousta z vás asi
neví, o čem teď budu mluvit,
ale přes to řeknu.
Rozpočet uvolňuje vlastně
takzvaně baru
jako dopředu
vlastně psat náklady.
My jdeme touto cestou.
Příslib je prakticky
vám řeknu takovou věc.
Jde o to,
o čem jsem mluvil, to znamená,
abyste maximálně využívali
a efektivně využívali to saldo.
To znamená ten zůstatek
nebo tu rezervu, kterou máte.
Příslibem toho moc nevyřešíte,
protože já vám řeknu,
pokud chcou mít lepší číslo na plnění,
tak řeknu, že
to pokryju, vykryju příslibem,
ale já se ptám, jestli v tom účetním období
ten příslib budete realizovat,
takže vlastně
máte lepší číslo,
ale efekt je úplně stejný.
To znamená, my jdeme jinak.
My nechceme hrát na to,
že budeme mít lepší číslo.
Když se podíváte,
když se podíváte na tu tabulku,
kterou jsme vám posílali,
a to jsou vlastně preferované projekty,
tak my je plánujeme v roce
a propisujeme do toho baru.
Takže my hedžujeme ty peníze na příští rok
a nemůžeme už je utratit.
Proč? Tady bychom schvalovali příští na nic.
My to schválíme rozpočtem.
Takže, a může nastat situace,
že třeba teďka budeme schvalovat,
jo, příští bod je sourozpočtová opatření,
kdy nakrýváme Sportovina Vršava a dostavba radnice ve Zlíně,
kdy chceme soutěžit vlastně dostavbu radnice a dáváme tam 20 milionů.
A v tuto chvíli si nejsme jistí,
jestli ty peníze opravdu jako do toho konce roku vysoutěžíme, uděláme.
To je to, o čem mluvil pan primátor,
že z hlediska té realizace pracujete s určitou mírou předpokladů.
A může se stát, že v příštím roce,
že do konce roku těch 20 milionů neutratíme,
ale my je převedeme, oni už zůstanou na tom orbu
a pokud je neutratíme dnes, tak je utratíme příští a příští rok
zase budeme už na to přidělovat peníze.
A tím se dostáváte do toho,
že z toho salda máte věci,
které v tom saldu už vám zůstanou,
jenom opravdu ty volné prostředky,
protože ty ostatní věci vlastně v tom baru
čtyři roky dopředu propisujete, jo.
Takže je to trošku jako složitější.
Já znovu říkám, vždycky je to v té přípravi
a v té realizaci, je to,
nedá se to úplně přesně typnout, jak to bude,
hlavně u takových akcí, které přesahují třeba 1, 2,
nebo 1, nebo 3 roky, jo.
Tam je to poměrně jako složitý, jo.
Protože udělat dneska splácení, dejme tomu kina v letech,
bude poměrně složitý, jo.
Ale víme, že ty peníze potřebujeme nějakým způsobem řídit, jo.
Jinak, a i když neutratíme ty peníze,
tak my je samozřejmě zhodnocujeme,
takže to není tak jako, že by to leželo někde v kanceláři
paní Olcové, ale ty peníze dál pracují v náš prospěch, jo.
To se tam snaží.
Takže jo, že to jednou k tomu.
Dobré, děkuji. Poprosím pana Prchala.
Dobré, dopoledne dámy a pánové.
Tento bod se jmenuje Závěrečný účet
a účetní závěrka za tutarního města Zlín.
Po profesní stránce ten dokument je připraven naprosto dokonale.
Krásně se v tom orientuje.
Graficky je to nádherné.
Za to bych chtěl celému oddělení poděkovat.
O tom, jaké jsou jednotlivé potom body
a jejich čerpání, to už je věc druhá,
ale myslím si, že tohle nepatří k tomuto bodu.
Proto za mě jenom děkuji všem, kteří na tom spolupracovali.
Tím moc krát děkujeme. Poprosím pana Vančuru.
Dámy a pánové, děkuju pane primátore za slovo.
Já se nicméně vrátím k té diskuzi,
protože myslím, že to je důležité.
Takže myslím, že to je důležité.
Bylo to jedno, ta výše realizovaných investic proti plánů.
To byla jedna skutečně z bodů, která nás zahybala.
My jsme tady před časem přešli na radnici.
A vedli jsme kolem toho docela dost diskuzí.
Můžu potvrdit, co jste říkal, pane primátore,
předchozí náměstek ekonomických, pane Chalánku.
Ten pokládal tu 40-50% hranici v realizaci investic za výborné číslo.
Zdá se to být jako samozřejmě trošku zmatečné,
ale myslím, že tam by bylo potřeba i trošku objasnit některou metriku,
kterou my tam používáme při té přípravě investic, její zařazování časové atd.
Ale v každém případě ta oblast investic, o tom asi nikdo nepochybujeme,
je pro město hodně důležitá.
Víte, že dlouhodobě stojíme o to, aby v této věci byl větší přehled,
nejenom to, co máme za sebou, ale především to, co nás čeká.
Stojíme o to a myslím, že se ta situace podstatně zlepšila
proti té minulosti priorizat těch jednotlivých projektů.
A vůbec v náhledu, jak o tom nadále přemýšlet,
samozřejmě i na pozadí toho ekonomického vývoje,
protože kdybychom letos dokázali všechno postavit,
tak ten schodek by byl zase o mnoho, o mnoho větší.
Ale co se týče těch investic, ještě chvilku se o to zdržím.
Víte, že, nebo alespoň my si to myslíme,
jsme o tom přesvědčení, že ten klíč k té úspěšné investici
leží v zadání toho projektu, ve spolupráci s projektovým ústavem,
až po samozřejmě nejenom tu realizaci a výběru dovatele,
ale taky o vyhodnocení toho projektu,
protože tam je potřeba podle naší zkušenosti
učit se nejenom z toho, co se povedlo,
ale to, co třeba s nebylo uděláno optimálně.
A já to říkám taky proto, že si myslíme,
že v této oblasti ještě máme na městě rezervy
a z druhé strany se cítíme být docela kompetentní
v této oblasti a tak už jsme připraveni,
myslím, městu v tom dalším odluji pomoci.
Vstavět dneska cokoliv,
to, myslím, každý potvrdí, kdo má něco za sebou,
není nic snadného a myslím si,
že je tam hodně práce a potřebujeme tam
soustředit ten potenciál města do této oblasti,
tak snad. Děkuju za pozornost.
Dobrá, množská děkuju za ten příspěvek
a poprosím pane Juráše.
Dobrý den, pane primátore, děkuju za slovo.
Dobrý den kolegyně, kolegové.
Já moc děkuju za tu diskuzi.
Naopak si myslím oproti panu Prchalovi,
že při schvalování závěrečného účtu
tato diskuze by měla nutně být.
A souhlasím s panem primátorem
i s panem Chalánkem, že ta diskuze
k té struktuře těch investic je spíše o metrice.
Ona není až tak o tom proinvestování,
když to zní zvláštně z prostého důvodu,
že hold více leté investice se nezařazují
do toho rozpočtu mechanicky.
To znamená ani finální hodnotou,
ale ani poměrnou částí.
Prostě to, co se proinvestovává v daném roce,
se vezme v potaz.
Proto, možná to pan Chalánek říkal trošku složitě,
já si to pokuším zjednodušit.
Ono to plánování a pak to řízení toho ročního rozpočtu,
to je vlastně řízení cash flow,
nikoliv jako naplánování stráty
nebo naopak přebytkového uspodaření.
To si myslím, že tak úplně nestojí.
Pokud bysme se spíše bavili o tom,
jaké procenta mají v tom roce být proinvestováno,
tak se de facto baví o nějakých střednilobých výhledech
a toho, jaké investice já jsem nachystal v té struktuře.
A to je všechno, co jsem k tomu chtěl říct. Děkuju.
Dobrá, děkuju taky za ten příspěvek, za to do vysvětlení.
A vzhledem k tomu, že nikdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak já prosím, pojďme lasovat materiál číslo 5.
Pro 34, materiál číslo 5 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 6 jsou rozpočtová opatření.
Chtěl bych tomu otržit diskuzi, jestli tomu máte nějaké otázky.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, tak prosím, pojďme lasovat materiál číslo 6.
Pro 29, materiál číslo 6 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 7 je Valná hromada společností vodovody a kanalizace,
kdy pověřujeme pana náměstka Pavla Bradu, aby zastupoval město na této Valné hromadě.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, tak prosím, pojďme lasovat materiál číslo 7.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 7 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 8 je poskytnutí finančního daru pro hasičský záchranný z bohořadinského kraje.
Kdybych se zeptal, jestli jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy.
Poprosím pana Mitáčka.
Děkuji, pane primátore, dobré, dopoledne, milé kolegyně, kolegové.
Já samozřejmě se musím zeptat, proč? Proč snižujeme žádost z 500 000 na 100 000?
A protože mě toto téma sami víte dlouho zajímá a sleduju to tady už v druhé volobní období,
až jsme se, nebo já osobně s ničím podobným tady nesetkal za těch 8 let,
tak mi to nedalo, volal jsem panu řediteli Rušově,
na hasičský záchranný z bohořadinského kraje a vedl jsem s ním o tom dlouhý rozhovor.
On mi zase oplátkou řekl o setkání, které měl jste členy rady a o informacích, které mezi vámi proběhly.
Nicméně, já bych to chtěl malinko toto téma tady zvednout, rozebrat a rád od vás budu slyšet ty pravé upřímné důvody.
Jenom připomenuji, že krajské město Zlín má tady ve Zlíně největší hasičskou stanici v celém Zlínském kraji a, jak říkám, předcházejících 8 let, kdy tady sedím,
a podpora tomuto sboru a této stanici odpovídala velikosti krajského města a odpovídala tomu, co ta stanice opravdu potřebovala.
Na oplátku město dostávalo samozřejmě vyřazenou techniku, která dár slouží dobrovolný hasičům ve městě Zlíně, opakovaně cisterny a další věci.
Myslím si, že tato spolupráce vždycky dlouhodobě fungovala a tady cítím, že začíná být narušená.
Jenom pro srovnání a pro kolegy, kteří možná nemají úplně přesné informace o tom, jak to vypadá v jiných městech v našem kraji,
tak 100 000 Kč dává jako podporu města například Holešov.
Snižujeme se na úroveň města Holešov? Čím?
Město v Setín dává třísta tisíc třeba.
Pro mě ta částka 500 000 Kč je částkou, která není nijak přehnaná a přemrštěná,
vzhledem k tomu, co oni požadují a vzhledem také k tomu, co vidím,
že je město schopno vydávat za peníze do jakých oblastí a co třeba vy jako rada podporujete.
Jenom namátkou zrovna dnešní materiálu jsou věci, kdy dáváte skoro 950 tisíc na videa
podporující skatepark a dostavbu přístavbu radnice.
Téměř milion korun.
A proti tomu stojí tady zbor, který potřebuje zařízení na prokazatelnou záchranu lidských životů.
A to je možná to, kde my se nacházíme, že pro vás ta hodnota je udělajme video
a pro mě ta hodnota je pojďme zachraňovat životy našich spolou občanů.
A jenom připomenu to, co tady před chvilkou říkal pan Chalánek.
A já si za jeho výroky stojím, když mluvil o financích.
Jsme tady pro občany.
Podtrhuji, podepisuju.
Další vaše věta.
Nebojíme se velkých projektů.
Podtrhuji, podepisuju.
A jak vám to jde dohromady tady s tímto?
Takže musel jsem k tomu vystoupit, musel jsem k tomu vyjádřit,
Protože není toto vystoupení jenom pro mě tady na úrovni města,
ale samozřejmě všichni, co jste zastupitelé z Línského kraje víte,
že k tomuto tématu pravidelně vystupuji i na krajské úrovni.
A jsem velmi rád, že po letech mé kritiky tyto zbory přichází s něčím,
co sami buď nemohou nafasovat.
Nejsou to žádné s proměnutím věcidení spotřeby,
ale jsou to zařízení, které opravdu potřebují
a prokazatelně vedou k záchraně lidského života.
Prosím, pane primátore, jestli můžete teď tento návrh ještě změňte.
Pokud k tomu nemáte sílu, nebo nemůžete, nebo jste se dohodli jinak,
tak já předložím pro ti návrh. Děkuju.
Já to uvedu v celku jednoduše a prostě no.
To vlastně s vámi, že dlouhé roky spolupráce fungovala,
fungovala na té bázi, s čím za námi došli,
tak tím vícem jsme vždycky vyšli v stříc,
a nebylo to o 500 tisících, to víme všichni tady.
Ale abychom mohli v této spolupráci pokračovat,
tak musí být dodrženy dohody s obou dvou stran.
To se v ní nestalo.
Takže vzhledem k tomu, že se nestal,
že nebyla naplněná dohoda ze strany,
která byla vlastně učiněna v vlenském roce,
nebyla naplněná ze strany vlné města,
tak první návrh byl, že je zamítneme úplně,
vzhledem k tomu, že se nedrží dohody.
Pak se řeklo, že teda, abychom dostalňují velké téma na zastupitelstvu,
což teď víceméně tady je,
tak jak jste to otevřel, že jsme výsledku tí,
tí, kteří jsou tí zlí, kteří hasičům něco nedávají,
protože zachraňují životy.
My jsme si to úplně vědomi,
ale pokud se hlavně hasiče financuje stát,
jsme si všichni taky vědomi.
Vždycky něco potřebovali, vždycky za námi došli,
vždycky jsme vyšli v stříd.
Vždycky tomu tak bylo.
A nebylo to o 100 tisícových částkách.
Jediné, co chceme, je, aby se na čem dohodneme, to platí.
V současné době tomu tak není,
proto jsme řekli, že místo 50 tisíc záváme 100 tisíc.
V týpadě se naplní dohody, které byly uzavřeny mezi námi,
tak vlastně vůbec nebráníme se tomu tu dotaci,
nebo ten dar následně navýšit.
Je to teďka čistě o tom, bavíme se o vyřazené technice,
kterou jste tady s nás zmínil.
Prostě víceméně my to akceptujeme,
jejich změnu postoje, ale v tu danou chvíli,
jako pokud se argumentuje historicky něčím
a je nějaká dohoda, že potom nějaká technika
bude darována nebo bude poskytnuta městu z línu,
a my na základě toho poskytneme nějaké finanční prostředky v minulosti
a následně se to tak nestane, tak v tu danou chvíli si myslím,
že je naprosto adekvátní to, abychom nebyli tak vstřícní
ve chvíli, kdy do jakákoliv žádost,
a ve chvíli, kdy se tyto věci, ty historické naplní,
tak určitě za sebe já počítám s tím,
že tady ten dar navýšíme.
To asi je na dovýsvětlení.
Není to teďka vůbec o tom, že bychom jakkoliv si podceňovali
jakoukoliv práci a podobně, ale prostě nastala změna postoje
u hasičů a v tu danou chvíli
když se něčem dohodneme, tak to má platit.
To je za nás.
A hlavně jsme se taky bavili, že je potřeba říct,
že na základ těch dohod jsme ty finance dávali vyšší,
než bývalo zvykem, než bylo to půl milionu.
A proto prostě říkáme, že když to neplatí,
tak ve výsledku my tohle zdáváme teďka 100 tisíc
a pokud se ty dohody naplní, tak prostě samozřejmě počítám,
bo já zase počítám s tím, že se budeme bavit o částce,
abychom dorovnali například těch 500 tisíc,
nebo možná se budeme bavit zase o něčem dalším.
Není to teďka otázka toho, že my bychom stropovali,
je tady nějaký zvyk 500 tisíc,
ten zvyk jsme několikrát porušili tím,
že jsme ho navýšili, tu částku,
ale kam ty věci musí platit.
To je za nás ten důvod,
že tam nyní 100 tisíc.
Celá otrpení.
Poprosím ještě, Jelomitáče, jste reagovat?
Ano, děkuji, pane primátor, jenom dovětek.
Já jsem tuto odpověď očekával.
Mohu vás v tomto i chápat,
ale nemyslím si, že zrovna občan chtěl slyšet to,
že něco handlujeme s hlasickým záchranným zborem a městem.
Já jsem ty důvody slyšel a nechtěl jsem je zveřejňovat,
protože si myslím, že je to věcí vás členů rady a druhé strany.
Ale pořád se na to prostě dívám
z nějakého dlouhodobějšího hlediska,
nějaké continuity toho,
že tady ta spolupráce nějak byla nastavená
a také té reality toho,
že oni nepřichází s něčím, co by jim leželo ve skladu
nebo neměli třeba využité.
Tam bych měl sám s tím problém.
Proto mi ta faktická stránka toho daleko sáhle přesahuje.
To, co může třeba probíhat krátkodobě v rámci toho,
jak vy říkáte, nedodržení dohod.
Podle mě je to zase jenom o nějaké komunikaci a jednání,
ale narušovat tím nějakou kontinuitu a vztahy,
které tady dlouhodobě byly budované
a samozřejmě dál musí pokračovat,
já považuji opravdu za nevhodné.
Proto mi dovolte podat protinávrh k tomuto bodu návrhové komisy.
Děkuju.
Děkuji, prosím náměstka, pana Volfa.
Dobré, dopoledne taky ode mě.
Pane kolego, já na vás budu reagovat, než utečete.
My jsme v podstatě loni tady schválili dar pro HZS
v nějaké částce přes 1 300 000,
což si myslím, že převyšuje ty pravidelné 500 000 přislíbené dary,
které dáváme každý rok.
A tenhle dar měl být v podstatě využit
na nákup vyproštěvacího zařízení.
Samo město Zlín zřizuje 12 dobrovolných jednotek hasičů
a 13. profesionální jednotku našich hasičů města Zlína.
V podstatě technika je zastaralá a musíme ji obnovovat.
A neděláme to tak, jak to tady možná trošku zaznělo,
že je to něco za něco.
Je to nějaká vzájemná výpomoc.
My jim pomůžeme nakoupit to, co oni na co třeba nemají rozpočet.
Oni nám zase pomůžou v něčem jiném.
A pokud naše jednotky nejsou dostatečně vybavené,
sami potřebujeme vyměnit vyproštěvací zařízení,
které má, já nevím, 20-30 let.
Cisterny teďka máme dvě na servisu.
Každá bude stát 100 000 servis.
Tak v podstatě ty peníze, pokud mají jít do nějaké bezpečnosti,
tak je první potřeba si vybavit vlastní jednotky.
Dovybavit.
A potom můžeme ty dary rozdávat.
Takže já to beru tak.
Ten návrh samozřejmě na radě byl 500 000.
Jak říkal pan primátor, byly návrhy, ať nedáváme ani korunu.
Tak jsem rád aspoň za těch 100 000.
Ale naprosto souhlasím s tým, jak rada rozhodla,
protože máme vlastní povinnosti vůči našim členům jednotek,
vůči našim asičům.
A ty bychom měli splnit a potom můžeme rozdávat dál.
A myslím si, že ty částky, co tady zazněly,
v minulém roce to bylo přes 1 300 000,
před loni to bylo 800 000,
před tým 500, před tým zase 700.
Takže ty částky nejsou úplně nejmenší.
A vy jste mluvil o Holešovu.
Největší města ve Zlínském kraji nedávají víc než 250 000 Kč.
Takže když bych to řekl fakt špatně,
tak máme skoro předplaceno to, co jsme HZS dali za poslední roky.
A já věřím, že se to podaří zase navázat,
že ta spoluprace bude pokračovat,
ale je potřeba, aby byla maličko zájemná.
Takže děkuju.
Dobrá, moc krát děkuji za to do vysvětlení.
A poprosím pane Juráše.
Děkuju za slovo, pane primátore.
Já vůbec nepochybuji o upřímném zájemu
pana kolegy Mitáčky a o vybavenosti
složek integrovaného záchranného systému.
A naopak to ocenuju.
Poprosil bych ho však, aby nám vysvětlil,
proč v pondělí na krajském zastupitelstvu,
kdy o podobnou vybavenost žádala policie České republiky.
Naopak vystoupil s podnětem, že to je záležitost státu,
ministerstva vnitra, které má vybavovat tenhle záchranný sbor.
A tady u hasičů říká, že to je záležitost kraje.
Druhou věc, kterou bych poprosil vysvětlit,
a to jenom jako fakt v dobrém,
já nemyslím to nějak ofenzivně,
v předchozím bodu bylo vyčítáno,
že hospodaříme s deficitem.
A teď se tady vlastně přikláníme k nějakému nákladu,
které se rada snaží jenom manévrovat
z pohledu toho, co udělal předtím,
tak jenom jestli byste mi to vysvětlili, děkuji moc.
Pohorsím teda o reakce pana Mitáčka.
Děkuji. Byl jste přítomen, vím o tom,
viděli jsme se tam a slyšeli.
Naopak ta moje reakce byla přesně opačená,
že v minulých letech policie přicházela s věcmi,
které mohly běžně fasovat ve svých skladech.
A právě tam z mé strany bylo poděkován,
že konečně minulý rok i letos přišly s materiálem a věcmi,
které nemohou běžně nafasovat
a běžně ministerstvo vnitra nepodporuje.
Naopak se tím otvírá ten prostor pro místní zprávu,
krajskou zprávu a pro peníze z našeho regionu,
protože je to podpora přímočinností,
které trápí tady regionální policii.
Takže ta moje poznámka byla přesně tímto směrem.
Děkuju.
A ještě bylo něco k financím?
Co se týká těch financí, tak mně to právě nejde dohromady s tím,
že na jedné straně vydáváme ty peníze třeba na propagaci videa,
které si myslím, že kdyby tady radní vzali svůj mobil,
natočili se tam, udělali toho Rios a zveřeněli to za položku nula,
tak my na to vydakládáme skoro milion korun.
Tak to mi právě přišlo ve vztahu k tomu,
jak mohou denně používat naši kolegové hasiči
při vyproštěvání našich spoluobčanů.
Trošku fakt nefér.
To bylo to porovnání s těmi financemi. Děkuju.
Já vás jenom poprosím,
vy jste tady dvakrát zvěděli nějaké videa za milion,
mohl byste mi říct, že to v těch materiálech vidíte.
Já si přiznám, že na Raděc teda řešíme všechno možné
a v poslední videa, co jsme neřešili,
tak jedno video bylo v hodnotě necelých deset tisíc korun.
Takže já jenom teda, když teda opakovaně zazdívám
na veřejném zastupitelstvu tvrzení,
že rada města Zína si objednává jako videa za milion korun,
tak bych byl rád teda, kde jste k této informaci přišel,
protože já i těch materiálek nevidím, co přiznám.
Tak děkuju. Rozpočtové opatření schválená Radou.
A je to strana, Katka mi říká 467, tabulka 2.
Já taky, než tam nalistuju, tady toho materiálu je hodně.
A je tam 700 tisíc na skatepark a 250 na dostavba radnice.
Je tam videa a propagace publicita a tyto materiály, tyto věci.
Já vás poprosím, na stránce 467 je jenom tabulka
a rozpočtová opatření jako pomlčka,
jste dvouřádková tabulka, tam to určitě na této stránce to není.
Důfám, že máme aktualizovaný program.
Já bych jenom chtěla říct, že když se aktualizuje program
a vy si uděláte do předešlého programu poznámky
a stáhnete si ho, tak ty poznámky zmizí.
Takže prosím vás, stáhněte si program z předevčerejška,
který přišel a tam to najdete na straně 467.
Nemoc se omlouvám, nevím, jak můžu pomoct, je to tabulka číslo 2
a je to rozpočtové opatření, které 0248, jako těžko se v tom fakt hledá ta poznámka.
Já už potom neaktualizuju, protože já už ztratím své poznámky.
Je to navědomí.
Můžu přijít se svým počítačem ukázat to.
Jo, my to prověříme, protože v současné době, co vykazuje pan Témní,
tak rozuměli jsme v milionových částkách, to za prvé,
ale prakticky říkám, to je čistě o tom, že samozřejmě v rámci města Zína
zhospodaříme adekvátně a není to o tom, že bychom se objednávali videa za milion.
Takže já bych jako chápu, že jsme v nějakém období, ale asi...
Ještě, jestli můžu, tak v novějším materiálu už je to lépe vyspecifikované.
V tom předešlém materiálu je napsané, že se jedná o přesun finančních
prostředků dle charakterych výdajů z investis do provozu v rámci akce
modernizace z K-Partku Bartoška na uhradu publicity. Akce 700 000. Publicita.
To ano, ale to je něco jiného, to není svou žádná videa.
Ale tak to čteme my, jo? To jsme se na to chtěli zeptat, proto tady kolega...
To nemá s žádnými videí nic společného, takže si to je tistá doměnka,
takže já bych potřeba přištěkně si to řekneme, jak tady věci jsou.
Ale prakticky tomu tak není, takže já jsem to chtěl si říct právě,
jestli jste k tomu přišli, že jsem to opakovaně tady říká. Děkuju.
Prosím ještě, jestli ten pan náměstek mě nechala něco říct tomu.
Pane primátore, já bych navázal na to, co říkal pan Juráš, ale to říká přesně o tomto.
Profesionální hasiči je státní zpráva. My můžeme podpořit a podporujeme v té výši,
když to řekneme, a teď se vrátím znovu o tom trendu, o kterém mluvil pan kolega Wolf.
500 tisíc tam dáváme, dáváme, přišli, že potřebují člun, aby ho koupili,
takže jsme tam dali 1,3, čili když to vypočítáte za poslední čtyři roky,
tak se dostanete do toho očekávaného jakési do té zvyklosti 500 tisíc.
Potom je druhá věc, když tady vzpomínáme ty občany, jak se my staráme o občany,
jako z hlediska požádní bezpečnosti a tady těch lidí,
kteří zajišťují bezpečnost a mimořádných situací k podporu našich obyvatel.
Tak jenom, když si najdete stranu 55 závěrečného účtu,
tak tam vidíte požádný ochrana, integrovaný záchranný systém.
My jako jedno z mála měst máme profesionální jednotku hasičů,
která na nás stojí závěrečného účtu 14 milionů korun.
14 milionů korun.
To, co říká pan Mitáček, jak se staráme a jde nám o ty občany,
ano, ne o 400 tisíc víc pro hasiče státní,
ale my platíme svoji jednotku.
Je to celkem taková mimořádnost.
Já jsem dokonce byl celkem dost aktivní o tom,
aby jsme to nějakým způsobem redukovali.
Ono to nejde, protože to právě v tom integrovaném záchranném systému
už nějak je zakomponované.
Takže vytáhnout to, zajistit tu službu už není vůbec jednoduché.
Pokud nám jde do toho občana, tak náš občan od města dostává
14 milionů z hlediska rozpočtu na víc, co ne úplně všude je.
A druhá věc je, a tady se znovu vracím k tomu,
kde máme mi povinnost, že řešíme teďka, paní Bláhová,
by vám určitě řekla, jako na Velíkové hasičárno,
protože tam nemáme kde zaparkovat vůbec to auto.
Jeho předpokladané rozpočet je 8 milionů korun
a budeme se bavit teda o tom, jak to nějakým způsobem vyřešíme.
Takže já bych teďka řekl, víc na mě doléhá jako,
myslím si, že máme o občany víc získat rozpočtu,
vynakládáme daleko víc než jinde, to je první věc.
Druhá věc, máme odpovědnost a musíme nějakým způsobem
dořešit hasiče jako na Velíkové.
A teďka jako se omlouvám, ale jestli náme hasičům,
jako jsme teďka zrovna v letošním roce nepřijeli jako 400 tisních,
oproti zvyklosti, která byla, tak si myslím jako, že si s tím,
musí nějak poradit.
Dobré, děkuju, poprosím pana Vančuru.
No já děkuju, pane primátore.
Já přemýšlím na celou tu diskuzi, jestli jsme se dostali tam, kam jsme vlastně potřebovali.
Teď to vypadá, že někdo je víc odpovědný, někdo méně odpovědný
a někdo víc nebo méně v jiný.
Myslím, že bylo fajn, kdyby tyto věci, pokud jsou k nim připomínky, se projednaly v pondělí na klubech,
kde bychom si to vysvětlili, asi pravděpodobně nebyl čas, aby tam ze stanu někdo přišel.
Ale myslím, že to obecně bychom se na to mohli dohodnout, pokud cítíme,
že máme témata, které potřebujeme objasnit, aby jsme si to provrali mezi sebou
a pak podle toho výstupu to prezentovali na zastupitelstvu.
Myslím, že lidi, kteří se to týká, nakonec si to nezaslouží. Děkuju.
Naprosto s vámi souhlas. Děkuju za tu připomínku.
Poprosím ještě pan Aleš Eduvka jako předsedu návrové komise,
aby přednesl protinávrh, co mu předložil pan Mitáček.
Takže dostali jsme písemné znění protinávrhu. Formálně je v pořádku.
Je k tomuto bodu a jeho znění je přečtu. To znamená, mělo by se hlasovat
o poskytnutí finančního daru ve vši 500 tisíc korun českých pro jasický záchrany
sboru Zlínského kraje se sídlem Přílůská 213 7601 Zlín,
IČ 7088 7306, na pořízení věcných prostředků dle důvodové zprávy.
Dobrá, moc děkuji za to přednesení. Jako se diskusně do další nehlásí,
tak v první řadě pojďme hlasovat o tomto protinávrhu, který byl podaný.
Pro 9 tento návrh nebyl přijat a prosím pojďme tedy hlasovat o materiálu číslo 8,
tak jak byl přednesen v materiálech, to znamená tentokrát od daru ve výši 100 tisíc.
Zlínského kraje 6, materiál číslo 8 byl přijat. Materiál číslo 9 je dodatek číslo 10
sýkající se smlouvy o veřejných službách přeprave cestujících.
Koukumu dotazy. Nikdo se v diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 9.
Pro 32 materiál číslo 9 byl přijat. Materiál číslo 10 je smlouva o smlouvě budoucího veřejných službách
na území, v přeprave cestujících, na území satelitárního města Zlína.
Koukumu nějaké dotazy. Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 10.
Pro 32 materiál číslo 10 byl přijat. Materiál číslo 11 je implementace
integrovaného území strategie. Jsou k tomu dotazy, poprosím pana Vančuru.
Střed zájmu. Ano, děkuji. Nikdo další se nehlásí, pojďme prosím hlasovat materiál číslo 11.
Pro 33 materiál číslo 11 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 12 týkající se pozemků a majetkoprávní úkonů. Jsou k tomu dotazy,
poprosím paní Francovou.
Já bych se chtěla zeptat. Tady máme tabulku číslo 7, kdy schvalujeme uzavření kupní smlouvy,
s čemž komise majetková přišla se sdělením, že nesouhlasí.
Také se nám tady objevuje nesouhlas s odborem městské zeleně.
Chtěla jsem zeptat, proč to teda, když jsem se dívala na ten nákres, proč to děláme, jestli je to tak strašně důležité.
A s tím vlastně souvisí i tabulka číslo 8, kdy v podstatě se objevují stejné nesouhlasné stanoviska.
Takže je tam v podstatě do budoucna ohrožený vstup na pozemky, které bychom mohli potřebovat.
Takže jsem se chtěla zeptat, jestli možná to z toho nákresu nechápu úplně dobře.
Ale pokud by tam zůstal nějaký zbytek, který by byl nepřístupný městu, tak mně přijde nesmysl to prodávat.
Z toho nákresu to není úplně jako jednoznačné, nevyznám se v tom, tak jestli mi to někdo může vysvětlit, proč to děláme.
To je ta přístupová komunikace vlastně na zadní pozemky. My jsme to řešili na radě, ale prakticky pokud si pamatuju správně,
tak my jsme řešili, že ten přístup vlastně zůstane zachovaný přes jinou lokalitu.
Ale teďka poprosím vidím paní vedoucí Úsákovou, jestli by nám v tom úplně řekla, je to vlastně věc týkající se vedle ulice Hořejší.
Je to vlastně komunikace v poli, kdybych to nazvala.
To není přímo komunikace, je to vlastně průh pole. A v tom jednom případě říkali, že to nedává logiku, jenže město prodává vlastně jako celý ten průh dvěma žadatelům.
A je to pozemek, který je jako solitární a není napojený na nic dalšího.
To si nemyslím, že by bylo, no, protože to brali jakože u té jedné části, jo, ale ty případy nešly úplně jako souběžně,
a my do těch stanovisek už potom nezasahujeme. Takže tím to vzniklo.
Děkuju, ještě poprosím pana náměstka Pavla Bradu.
Dobré dopoledne všem. Tak já si ještě několik informací k tímto pozemkům. Samozřejmě jsme to detálně probírali,
to nejsou přístupové pozemky, jsou to v podstatě nějaké zbytkové pozemky zahrady.
V podstatě pokud přišla jedna žádost na ten pozemk, tak jsme dali podnět ze strany majetku,
aby se to prodalo jako celek, aby městu nezůstal nějaký tam zbytkový pozemek.
A v podstatě udělali jsme znalecký posudek a je to prostě nějaká i reálná tržní cena.
A ten pozemek byl pro město nějakým zůsem nevyužitelný a neviděli jsme důvod v tomto případě ho nějak držet.
Takže samozřejmě pokud v jiných případech, kdy prostě máme možnost ten pozemek nějak zhodnotit,
něco s ním udělat nebo tam něco vybudovat, tak samozřejmě neprodáváme tady,
nám to přišlo, nedávalo smysl tento pozomek držet.
Dobrá, děkuji. Jsou k tomu nějaké další dotazy?
Nikdo se v diskuze nehlásí, tak prostě vzhledem to, že nejsou žádné protinávrhy,
tak pojďme hlasovat materiál 612 tak, jak byl předložen.
Pro 28, materiál 612 byl přijat. Materiál 613 týkající se majetko právní úkonů,
tentokrát o prodej pozemků majiteli objektu Tršnice, který tento objekt chce rekonstruovat,
a tam řešili jsme, jaké pozemky k tomu potřebuje,
protože v některých místech jsou pod touto budovou podzemní stavby,
takže potom se řešilo i využití těch pozemků v okolí Tršnice,
s tím, že jsme k tomu přistoupili v podobném duchu,
jako jsme přistoupili historicky k objektu obchodního domu.
Proto je to vlastně v tomto rozsahu.
Jsou k tomu dotazy?
Nikdo se diskuze nehlásí, pojďme prosím hlasovat materiál 613.
Pro 28, materiál číslo 13 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 14 je dohoda o společném postupu přípravy a realizace stavby s ředitelstvím stavnic Zinského kraje.
Jsou k tomu dotazy?
Nikdo se diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 14.
Pro 38, materiál číslo 14 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 15 se týká pozemků, které potřebujeme do budoucna na naší část propojení dální CD 49 a komunikace 1, 49,
to znamená tu městskou část nebude obchvat záležné.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se diskuze nehlásí, pojďme prosím hlasovat materiál číslo 15.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 15 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 16 týkající se pozemků a směných smluv ze rekonstrukcí místní komunikace Mezní a Michalova.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se diskuze nehlásí, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 16.
Pro 36, materiál číslo 16 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 17, opět pozemky.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 17.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 17 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 18 týkající se prodeje stavby asi na současné době, která se objížívá k parkování na střeše garáží, které jsou v majetku soukromého subjektu.
Je to určité narovnání vztahu, protože to parkování, které tam na této ploše probíhá, je asi soukromé za závorou, takže nejedná se o veřejné parkování.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 18.
Pro 30, materiál číslo 18 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 19 týká předkupního práva k bytovým jednotkám.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 19.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 19 byl přijat.
Pateriál číslo 20 týkající se investiční dotace z rozpočtu na zhodnocení sportoviště ve zprávě společnosti STEZA.
Prosím paní Francovou.
Já jenom k této investici. My jsme nedávno převzali ty tenisové kurty.
A mám takový pocit, že sotva to sportoviště převezmeme, tak i hned to vyžaduje poměrně nemalé finanční náklady.
Samozřejmě chápu, zadržování dešťové vody je určitě správná věc.
Co mě tady trápí, tak vybudování spevněné plochy pro posezení.
Tak doteďka se tam sedělo kde, když se hrál tenis.
A teď to musíme jako řešit. Jako, já vím, že 380 tisíc není mnoho, ale v podstatě, jak říká kolega, mohli jsme to dát na siču.
Ale jako teď teda neseděli nikde a my to teď musíme zachránit a dát 380 tisíc na to, aby se mělo kde sedět.
Tak to mě trošku trápí.
Prosím náměstky Jino Bazilovou.
Dobré dopoledne všem. Já jsem chtěla nahlásit střed zájmu, ale jinak tady máme pana ředitele Havlíčka, který k tomu může dát určitě fundované vysvětlení.
Dobré dopoledne, dámy a pánové, vážení pane primátore. Co se týče posezení na tenisovém areálu Mlacová, tak tam ten areál není jenom o tenise a o tenisových kurtech,
ale je to areál, který v podstatě zahrnuje i letní využití ve formě venkovního bazénu. My bychom rádi ten venkovní bazén letos zprovoznili.
A co se týká toho posezení, tak ta plocha, která tam byla, tak byla ve špatném stavu, musela se jako předělat, nebo musí se předělat.
To znamená, je tam nutná rekonstrukce pro to, když tam budou chodit rodiny s dětmi, tak aby si tam nespůsobili nějaké zranění.
Takže to je ten důvod, proč tu plochu tam teď momentálně dáváme dohromady.
Já to jenom doplním, tam se jedná o malý bazén, to znamená, on se využíval z pravidla na příměstské tábory a podobné.
Vlastně tyto akce, není to o tom, že bychom tam tady další veřejné koupaliště, ale samozřejmě bezpečnostního hlediska, pokud tam se má pořádat zase něco,
ať už jsou to tenisové kempy nebo nějaký jiný příměstský tábor, který by v těch letních měsících jako využíval tady to ochlazení, bych to řekl, než není o plavání, to spíš o tom opravdu by se ochlaďili,
tak samozřejmě tam musí být dostatečný přístup a který je bezpečný, což se nám teda, což se z pozice stezis technikových, který tam byl jako jeví, že je to potřeba opravit, takže proto to tady máme.
Poprosím ještě paní Francovou.
Tak já za sebe, jestli nám to přinese příjem, to znamená, že ten bazén pronajmeme, tak to s tím souhlasím.
Taky nějaký příjem to určitě přinese, protože my, když to poskytneme k dispozici teda veřejnosti, tak budeme tam vybírat nějaký vstup, tak jak na ostatních koupalištích.
Ale je to o tom, že bychom rádi celý ten areál využili a zpřístupnili veřejnosti a to už od teďka od začátku prázdního.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Níkdo se další do diskuze nehlásí, pojďme tady prostě hlasovat bod číslo 20.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 20 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 21 týkající dotací z fondů pro rodinných aktivit z programu A.
Zatací na 250 tisíc.
Jsou k tomu dotazy nebo střety zájmu?
Poprosím paní Francovou.
No, já bych chtěla nahlásit střet zájmu.
Dobře, děkuji.
Níkdo další se do diskuze nehlásí, takže pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 21.
Pro 31, materiál číslo 21 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 22 týkající se dotací na 250 tisíc ze sociálního fondu z programu A.
Jsou k tomu dotazy nebo střety zájmu?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, takže prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 22.
Pro 35, materiál číslo 22 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 23 se týká dotací na 250 tisíc ze sociálního fondu z programu C.
Jsou k tomu dotazy nebo střety zájmu?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, pojďme tedy prosím hlasovat materiál číslo 23.
Pro 37, materiál číslo 23 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 24 je změna ve jmenovitém složení komise v Jaroslavicích.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, tak prosím pojďme hlasovat o tom, že v tomto materiálu budeme hlasovat aklamací.
Pro 36 a můžeme tedy aklamací hlasovat samotný materiál číslo 24.
Pro 30, materiál číslo 24 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 25 je schvální smlouvy o společném postupu zadavatelů,
kdy jsme řešili v rámci města a městských organizací možné společné nákupy od různých služeb,
přes samozřejmě tady například ty kancelářské potřeby, takže tady je jedna z těch věcí,
které bychom rádi do budoucna kupovali společně, abychom se dostali k lepším cenám.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme na stav materiál číslo 25.
Pro 36, materiál číslo 25 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 26 je od souhlasení změn v úlevách v dízne v městské hromadné dopravě.
Vychází tento materiál vlastně z diskuze z předchozího zastupitelstva, kdy pan Skála přednesl návrh na snížení té věkové hranice pro jízdné zdarma.
Po zastupitelstvu proběhla diskuze právě s panem Skálou a s dopravním podnikem,
kdy jsme došli ke shodě na tom, že bychom tu věkovo hranici snížili na 75 let, aby to bylo stejné,
jako má zlínská integrovaná doprava, aby se nestávaly ty stavy, kdy člověk dojede zlínskou integrovanou,
nebo integrovanou dopravu z línského kraje, dojede do zlína a přestoupí na městskou hromadnou dopravu
a pokud má 76, 77 let, tak vlastně by musel, tak vlastně u nás platil.
Těch případů nebylo úplně mnoho, ale chápeme, že to bylo trochu zmatečné.
My jsme spolehali z toho otevření na to, že ve chvíli proběha integrace městské hromadné dopravy
do integrované dopravy z línského kraje, tak se vlastně ten věk srovná,
jelikož stále aktuálně, že ta integrace není v tomto ohledu dokončená
nebo není ještě ustanovaná, tak jsme se dohodli právě i s panem Skálou,
že dáme, že ten věk snížíme na 75 let a s tím, že město z límto
z největší plenství se, že bude stát nějaké finanční prostředky.
Až v praxe nám ukáže, v jaké výši budou, máte v důvodové zprávě
vlastně napsáno, jakou částu by se mohlo jednat. Zbavíme se, že by to mělo být zhruba,
pokud minimálně, tak jsme město přes 2 miliony korun.
Ty pesimistické názory jsou až 5 milionů korun.
Uvidíme se, že tu realitu, protože je to určitý odhad, kolik těch seniorů si kupovalo lístek
a tak dále. To znamená, uvidíme až z praxe, jakou částu navíc nám to přinese.
Tady to snížení TVK ve hranice o 5 let níže. Poprosím pana Skálu.
Děkuji za slovo, pane primátore.
Vážené dámy zastupitelky, vážení páni zastupitelé.
Jak vidíte, na minulém zastupitelstvu jsem to dal jako diskuzní příspěvek.
Potom jsme se rozhodli, že o tým nebudem hlasovat.
Tak já jsem podal příspěvek jako na dnešní zastupitelství, kde jsem zpracoval jednotlivé aspekty tohoto návrhu.
Po jednání s panem primátorem jsme dospěli k závěru, že každý ustoupíme kousek,
protože to má nějaké finanční nároky, jak říkal pan primátor.
A je potřeba to potom třeba po roce znovu vyhodnotit a ukáže se, jestli je možné ještě jít dále,
tak jak jsem navrhoval na těch 70 let, nebo to zůstane na 75.
Obrovskou výhodou toho, že se sjednotilo to, že městská hromadná doprava má stejné tarifní podmínky pro seniory,
tak jak má krajská doprava.
A myslím, že mám docela dost kladných ohlasů na to, že ti seniory opravdu to kvitují,
to snížení té věkové hranice, protože i když mají možnost zakoupit senior pasy,
tak senior, který jede dvakrát, třikrát za měsíc na úřad nebo do nemocnice,
nebude určitě využívat senior pas.
Takže já bych poděkoval za ten střicní přístup panu primátorovi a panu náměstkovi Číškovi a dalším,
že jsme se dohodli za cenu nějakých ústopků k tomu,
že prostě ty seniori to budou mít výhodnější a uvidíme do budoucna, jak se to všecko vyvine.
Děkuji vám za pozornost.
Moc děkuji za to doplnění. Já bych ještě informoval o jedné věci.
To, že o tom dneska budeme hlasovat na ještím zastupitelstvu,
tak jsem informoval také starostku Otrokovic, aby o tom věděli,
že vlastně my tady tento bod budeme mít.
Víceméně pokud ho schválíme, tak Otrokovice jsou připraveny přijmout tento bod také,
protože vlastně naše schválení bez schválení zastupitelstva Otrokovic je,
jak nechci říct, že bestané, ale je to jenom signálem, který se nepropíše,
protože je potřeba vlastně schválení obou dvou vlastníků.
Takže to spíš jenom, ať si to upřesníme, že ta informovánost do Otrokovic proběhla.
Otvírám diskuzi k tomuto bodu.
Do diskuze se nikdo nehlásí, takže prosím pojďme hlasovat o tom,
že by od 1.1.2027 byla tato bezplatná přeprava seniorů už od 75 let,
kdy ten termín je záměrně staven na 1.1.2027 právě proto,
aby město Otrokovice mohli zareagovat na naše usnesení zastupitelstva
a následět i dopravní společnost v případě schválení i zastupitelstva města Otrokovice.
Pro 36, materiál číslo 26 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 27 je smlouv o poskutní případku společníka mimo základní kapitál
do částečně vlastněné společnosti městem, to znamená do společnosti Beraní z lín.
Proběhla k tomu v pondělí relativně obsáhlý seminář,
někteří jsou zúčastní, někteří ne.
Na základě semináře ještě vznikly nějaké otázky.
Zcela otevřeně, já za sebe říkám, že ten obecně celý ten princip hokeje,
který teď řešíme už opakovaně, tak myslím si, že tady nikoho netěší.
A myslím za sebe opravdu, že je v zájmu asi nás všech,
učení kroky k tomu, abychom do budoucna tady tuto společnost mě stabilizovanou,
ať už tím, že do této společnosti vstoupí soukromý investor,
ať už majetkově, nebo s tím, že město svěří svá práva,
což teďka probíhá, když řeknu průzkum trhu,
tady jsme i získová zpráva byla k tomu zveřejněná včera,
s tím, že ten průzkum je už, myslím, od začátku týdne.
Zároveň je potřeba říci, že se diskutuje téma
s týkou hokejové licence, kdy samozřejmě hokejové licence z historického hlediska
je ve vlastnictví hokejového spolku.
To znamená, vzhledem k tomu, že hokejový klub, respektive
áčkový tým, to znamená to, na co chodí nejvíce diváků,
a co má největší sledovanost, a plní to do velké míry také společenskou
atraktivitu, když to řeknu města zlínán pro sortu lidí podobně,
jak je tomu u divadla, u zoo a u jiných vlastně našich spříspěkových organizací,
tak samozřejmě je do budoucna možné diskutovat o otázce,
že by tady tata společnost s ručením omezeným vlastně měla kompletní
příslušenství k tomu, co vykonává, a zároveň si myslím,
že by to v některých věcech mohlo být ku prospěchu, pokud bychom
zamezili případným rizikům, které by s ním souvisely.
Takže myslím si, že ta otázka není, abychom ji vůbec neotvírali.
Každopádně dnes jsme vlastně jenom v té debatě o příkladku,
aby společnost vedaní zlín mohla fungovat dále.
A myslím si, že kdo chtěl k tomu bližší informace,
tak opravdu byl v pondě na tom semináři, kde si myslím,
že obsahy informace jste dostali na vše, co jste potřebovali.
Poprosím, první srdisku zhlásí pan Janda.
Děkuji, pane primátore. Dobrý den, dámy a pánové.
Určitě se nepasuji na odborníka hokeje, ale chtěl jsem říct,
že v pondělí jsem se účastnil toho semináře.
Myslím si, že tam padlo spoustu objasňujících věcí,
kdy vedení hokeje nám sdělilo, jakým způsobem hospodařilo,
je připraveno řešit ty věci do budoucna.
Nicméně ta situace, jak víme, dneska máme na stole materiál
za 12,9 milionů korun, takže z hlediska ekonomiky
není úplně neoptimálnější.
Já jsem měl návrh, kdy jsem chtěl s tímto materiálem,
vidět to, jsou to peníze do SROčka, spojit to,
aby případný budoucí klient nebo partner,
který by nám do hokeje vstoupil, vlastně vlastnil tu licenci.
To znamená, nekupoval si jenom ty hráče,
ale koupil si něco, co vlastně mu zabezpečuje to,
aby tu Maxa Ligu hrál,
protože doteď to vlastně zapsaný spolek,
který je pod vedením,
a my tam vlastně jako město nemáme mimo zlaté akcie
žádný veliký vliv, takže chtěl jsem,
aby tahleta licence byla převedena tomuto klubu
anebo případně zabezpečena
na někde úplně samostatné SROčko,
které bude vlastnit město a které bude vlastně
vždycky rozhodovat a mít vliv na to,
aby tato licence
zůstala v podstatě
ve městě, zůstala pro ten
OK. Já čekám, že na základě
té diskuze, kterou jsme měli,
nebo případně budeme mít,
dojde k nějakému komplexnímu řešení,
jestli budeme pokračovat
tímto směrem, kdy v podstatě
po každém období máme významné ztráty,
jestli
budeme ty věci řešit
nejenom ekonomicky, ale i personálně
a samozřejmě ta licence je to poměrně zásadní,
kdy jsem si vždy myslel,
že Maxa Liga by ji měla
buď vlastnit,
nebo by ji měla mít natolik ochráněnou,
což u toho
zapsaného spolku, jak se zdá dneska, není.
Děkuji.
Jak jsem řekl, já si myslím, že tu diskuzi
hledně licence můžeme klidně otevřít.
Tam si myslím, že na tom není nic,
proč bychom to neměli udělat.
Každopádně musíme si pak
také zjistit, jaké
podmínky pro
držení této licence
stanovuje Český svaz letní hokeje,
které já z hlavě určitě nevím.
Je to jedna z těch věcí, které vlastně
nějakým způsobem může omezit
například tady tu debatu,
že bychom měli ještě například
jednu společnost ruční omezit, která by to vlastnila.
Uvidíme, prostě myslím si, že
co se týká hokejového klubu,
současnou vedení se
nikdo nebrání jakýmkoliv diskuzím,
protože jsou si vědomi toho, že
se snaží odvádět práci,
ale samozřejmě je to sport,
kdy všichni víme,
jaká sezona byla ta poslední
a jaké byly predikce před sezonou,
vypadala, takže samozřejmě můžeme si říct,
že s notnou dávkou štěstí
anebo pílem, můžeme si každý říct,
jak to dopojme, se na štěstí podařilo dostat do finále.
Takže když to řeknu po výsledkové stránce,
playoff určitě nebyl problém,
základní část byl velký problém.
Myslím si, že se z toho
všichni v daném klubu ponaučili,
ale zároveň říkám,
tak jak jsem deklaroval,
myslím si, že není problém otevří
jakékoliv diskuze.
A zároveň
já jenom to vnímám tak,
že je potřeba si říci,
jak to do budoucna
máme vnímat z pozice města Zdína
vlastně obecně ten,
ať už je to hokej, fotbal,
nebo jakýkoliv sport,
který prostě do nějaké míry
město,
s partnerem,
protože, tak jak jsem řekl,
z pozice města
se určitě za mě nedržíme
toho podílu v rámci
v rámci této společnosti.
Na druhou stranu určitě
zájmu města je, aby tady
nejen hokej byl zachován,
a je to určitá společenská
věc, která
zvyšuje atraktivitu města Zdína,
za kterou lidé k nám do Zdína dojíždějí.
To znamená, tak jak jsem říkal,
mimozninských obyvatel,
platíme tam 70 milionů ročně
a vlastně nikdo s tím nemá tady problém,
když to vezmu, a tady
vedle toho máme hokej s rozpočtem
přes 80 milionů korun,
město s ním tam dává
10 milionů korun bez DPH,
plus tady tyto příplat,
plus teďka teda příplatek,
a případně případky,
které tam probíhaly historicky,
to znám vysnáku garáže a podobně,
ať se nalijem čistého vína,
že to není pouze o těch desetí milionech,
ale když to srovnáte,
tak ono to plní podobnou společenskou událost,
jako nebo společnou společenskou roli,
jako například to divadlo,
nebo filharmonie, nebo prostě možná i ta zoo.
Takže tam je pak otázka toho vnímání,
jak to do budoucna máme vlastně si sami všichni vzít,
jak to máme brát,
protože když to budeme přepočítávat
na tady tu společenskou roli
a na dotaci na vstupenku,
tak samozřejmě se budeme bavit,
že dotace na vstupenku do divadla
nebo filharmonie je úplně někde jinde,
jako násobně jinde,
než to dáváme do sportovních akcí,
už je to fotbal nebo hokej,
volejbal házená, basketbal,
ale prostě určitě jsme za to rádi,
že tady tyto sporty máme
a je to prostě pro některé občany
a nejen zlínské občany atraktivní,
že tady můžou na tyto sporty dojít.
Takže je to vždycky otázka toho vnímání,
ale to, co si myslím,
že si tady přejeme naprosto všichni,
je vyřešit tady problematiku
společnosti beraní zlín SRO tak,
aby to nebylo téma každým rokem
na zastupitelsku,
že tam něco musíme doplatit
jinak ten spolek nebo respektive
společnost s určitým omezeným
prostě bude mít problém s cashflow
a s dalšími závazky.
Takže to si myslím,
že je pro nás téma pro všechny
a musíme si prostě říct,
jaké cesty k tomu vedou,
kdy jedna z těch cest je opravdu svěření
například těch práv,
výkonů práv těch 79% někomu,
kdo ten kapitál do toho klubu přinese.
A druhá varianta, že to zůstane na městě
a my si musíme vyhodnotit,
jako jak to zabezpečit tak,
aby to nebylo téma,
říkáme každý rok nebo nebo vícekrát za rok.
Poprosím paní Francovou.
Dneska možná naposledy.
Je to pravda,
já jsem si tady, pane primátore,
napsala to, co jste také řekl.
Jste za divadlo Zoologická filharmonie.
Město hradí rozvoj,
podílí se na udržování těch prostor.
Tomu všemu já rozumím.
Hokej patří mezi atrakce,
které navštivují děti, dospělí,
seniori, zdraví, postižení.
Určitě s tím také souhlasím.
Za mě mám trošku výtku spíš k tomuto systému.
Mně to přijde nezodpovědné od managementu,
že přišli tak pozdě.
Mně trápí to, že nám přednesli,
že zhodnotili ten stadion, investovali nebo opravili.
Teď nevím, pane Juráši, abych to řekla správně.
S tím také souhlasím.
Myslím si, že se ty kroky měly udělat dopředu.
Asi chápu, že tam nastoupili,
nebyly úplně dostatečně na to erudovaní,
aby jsme...
Protože úplně jinak by se nám schvalovalo
to dotace nebo schvalovali finance,
které klub dal do našeho majetku,
než teď v podstatě schvalovat nějaké finance,
které chybí na provoz.
Mám pocit, že teď to zpětně taháme
trošku jak kočku za ocas,
aby jsme to teda nějakým způsobem zvládli.
My jsme se tady dotazovali v lednu,
jak to vypadá.
Ta stráta tam byla nižší.
Byli jsme ujišťovaní, že se to nějak zvládne.
Jediné, co mě tak trošku jako na tom,
v pondělí na tom zasedání,
zarazilo bylo to,
to, že kdyby jsme nešli do playoff,
tak by stráta byla ještě větší.
Já jako děkuju za to,
že se tam pánové z hokeje odkryli,
že nám všechno řekli, ukázali čísla, data.
Bylo to super, bylo to dobré.
Mě to pak ve spoustě věcech přesvědčilo,
že je potřeba to vnímat i trošičku jinak,
než to, že je to hokej a zase platíme do hokeje,
že je to prostě ta atrakce a že nese s sebou peníze,
tak, jak nesou jiné sportoviště, kulturní aktivity, společenské aktivity,
ale mě vadí ten systém a přemýšlím,
jestli je tento management schopný,
a to já nevím, dohlídnout na to
a vytvořit správnou takovou vizi do budoucna,
protože pokud v lednu nedokážeme říct,
jak to bude vypadat teď a přemýšlet,
že když bychom hráli baráž, tak by to bylo dobré,
ale když bychom nehráli ani playoff,
tak by to bylo ještě horší, než to teď je,
tak toto mě trošku na tom trápí.
Já to určitě rozumím, prakticky je potřeba říct si,
že současné managementy tam došel,
tak došel ještě do větší ztráty,
než kterou teďka řešíme,
to znamená za ty své roky existence tohoto vedení,
se jako nemalá část té ztráty, kterou dneska řešíme,
se podařila srovnat,
jinak bychom dneska měli něco, co začíná dvojkou,
je potřeba říct si, reálný stav, do kterého přišli.
Takže si myslím, že ten současný management by měl být schopen
to nějakým způsobem do budoucna zase ještě posílit.
Na druhou stranu, ty možnosti jsou velmi omezené
z důvodu toho, jak ta firma funguje.
Tam je ten stav, když samozřejmě,
když to, co vám předpokladám příklad na tom semináři,
protože já jsem v pohodě mimo zlín,
tak jsem se to nemohl účastnit,
tak ten stav je, že vlastně obecně celou novou sezonu
a fiskální rok, teď to řeknu od fiskální rok 26-27,
ty státe, když to řeknu v lednu,
kdy končíte původní fiskální rok
a potřebujete již podepsat ty hráče,
jinak vlastně nemůžete,
nejste schopni podepsat,
teď to řeknu v červnu, v červenci a tak dál,
protože už na trhu prostě nejsou,
takže musíte řešit,
jdete do naprostého rizika toho,
že v lednu podepisujete,
v lednu uzavíráte smlouby
s hráči dle nějakého plánovaného rozpočtu,
který vlastně ve zlíně není navyšovaný za poslední 3 roky,
tuším, že není skoro, ne podle mě vůbec,
nejsem se tříka jistý,
ale myslím si, že není vůbec za poslední 3 roky
navyšovaný rozpočet na hráče,
ale vlastně máte z toho rozpočtu zhruba 80 milionů korun,
tak jediné, co v tom lednu máte,
tak je zpravidla pouze finance na propagaci města Zlína,
to znamenáte 10 milionů bez DPH
a to je všechno z toho 80 milionového rozpočtu,
co máte v ruce a věříte tomu,
že po sezóně nebo v průběhu té sezóny
vlastně ti partneři,
kteří nějakým způsobem podporují tedy tento klub,
tak ho budou podporovat alespoň ve stejné výši.
Můžeme si říkat, jestli je to dobře nebo špatně,
má to své výhody, nevýhody,
že teď to řeknu,
že ve Zlíně těch velkých partnerů není mnoho,
to znamená nejsme v situaci,
jako jsou některé jiné kluby,
kde tady mají 2-3 velké partnery,
kteří jim dávají v součtu 20 milionů korun a více.
My tu máme jednoho generála,
který dává nemalé finanční prostředky,
další tři firmy,
které jsou také v milionových částkách
a potom jste ve statisících,
to znamená těch partnerů je snad kolem 60,
které smlouvy musíte oběhnout a vůbec je mít.
To znamená, když vám někdo z nich vypadne,
tak aspoň to riziko je potlačené.
Na druhou stranu získat smlouvy od všech 60
nebo těch desítek partnerů každý rok
je extrémně náročné a zároveň
také vlastně vám to nějaký ústem nejisté
v rámci té tvorby.
Takže to je to, co říkám,
že je potřeba otevřít tu otázku,
jako jak s tím dál,
proto jsme i otevřeli tu otázku,
jestli to ten klub nikdo nějakým způsobem nechce
těch z nějaké míry,
to nemusí být 79%,
může být 51% a to je úplně jedno.
My teďka neřešíme ten majetek,
my řešíme vůbec ten princip toho kapitálu
a vlastně hledáme ty cesty,
jak to budou se nastavit,
protože těch cest moc není,
protože já jsem se o tom bavil s jinými primátory
napříč s Českou republikou
a většina z nich je ve velice podobném stavu,
kdy říkají bez toho,
aby tak, jak ve fotbale do fotbala vstupují,
když to řeknu miliardáři a jiní,
kteří ty kluby mají víceméně jako koníček,
nebo můžeme mít jako hračku,
nebo vlastně tam není o tom,
že nějakým způsobem extra vyděláváte,
na druhost no ten fotbal aspoň je,
má potenciál a můžete,
když budete mít dobrý scouting, dobrou výchovu mládeže,
tak jste schopni na tom nějakým způsobem vydělat
a fungovat asi třeba i v té nule.
V hokeji to bohužel není možné
a to je to, co řešíme napříč Českou republikou,
že vlastně bez toho,
vzal někdo, když to řeknu za jako svůj koníček,
že ví, že toho vícem bude doplácet,
tak v tu danou chvíli to vysí na těch městech
a vzhledem k těm parametrům,
jaké jsou nastaveny,
tak vlastně se to blíží do té podoby,
že to je neufinancovatelné,
nebo překlopení do té retoriky v těch hlavách všech
v rámci té České republiky,
že ten sport, konkrétně ten hokej,
který ve výsledku už budete mít dobrou výchovu mládeže,
tak vás ekonomicky nezabezpečí.
Navíc je tam otevřený trh,
samozřejmě velké ambice všech možných odcházet
i už v mladém věku, kamkoliv,
a vy to nejste schopni vlastně jakkoliv zastavit.
Když nepodepíšete smlouvy s rodiči
dvanáctiletého a desetiletých kluků a tak dál,
což samozřejmě zase potřebujete finanční prostředky,
a i tak samozřejmě můžou přestoupit do zahraničí,
nebo třeba říct,
že ten trh v tomto vás úplně neochrání.
Takže ten systém,
který je tam nastavený z pozice svazu,
není úplně šťastný,
protože vlastně opravdu je to černá díra,
která ačkoliv hrajeme,
řeknu pouze druhou nejvyšší soutěž v České republice,
tak i této soutěži to začíná být těžce ufinancovatelné,
a celý ten hokej v České republice se trošku transformuje do té podoby,
že jsou tu extraligové kluby a jejich farmy.
Když se podíváte, kolik týmů v první lize
je farmou nějakého, jak se říká farmou,
prostě s nějakým zpropojená s klubem extraligy,
kde je právě ten mecenáž,
a ten je pak schopný podepsat,
například místo 20 hráčů podepíše 35,
a ty zbytlí hráči, aby někde hráli,
tak je také pošlet do té první ligy,
do té své, na tu svou farmu,
a více mi je tím pomáhá tomu rozpočtu,
tak už jich není málo,
pak jich už začíná být většina.
A teď je prostě otázka,
celý ten svaz dneska stojí vlastně před otázkou,
jak to dobudou se nastavit,
ať už samotnou extraligu,
samotnou první ligu,
vůbec ten princip,
protože teďka ta prostupnost je jaká je,
to víme všichni,
a díky této, dá se říct,
z neprostupnosti se to transformuje
do tady nějakým zůstem této podoby,
a v první lize zůstávají tak dva až tři kluby,
kteří neustále řeší,
že nechtějí být tím farmářem,
ale chtějí být ve výsledku ten,
který je mezi těmi, kteří to hrají.
Takže kteří vícemě jsou v té extralize
a nejsou řekně závislí,
ale snaží se fungovat na té nejvyšší úrovni.
Takže uvidíme, jak to celé dopadne.
Každopádně, jak jsem řekl,
je to i otázka toho vnímání,
doteď je to bylo vnímáno,
je to sport,
sport si má na sebe vydělat,
je to nějaké historicky takto navnímané.
Já za sebe v tomto kontextu jsem strašně moc rád,
že ve fotbale máme dlouhodobě jednoho majitele,
který vícemě s tomu přistupuje racionálně,
ale opravdu jakékoliv ty problémy
má ten kapitál, aby to ustál.
A vlastně i díky němu hrajeme pořád ve fotbale nejvyšší ligu.
Ačkoliv také tam byl sestoup
a teď vlastně postup zpátky v minulých letech.
Ale je to prostě něco, co v současné době je ten trend,
že bez tady těchto, můžeme říct,
těch mecenášů nebo toho externího kapitálu
prostě to bude neufinancovatelné,
pokud se nezvění retorika těch jednotlivých zastupitelů,
že to začnou vnímat jako společenskou nepovinnost,
ale jako jednu z těch společenských atrakcí,
společenských věcí, co je potřeba v tom regionu udržet,
aby v tom regionu ti lidé tu atraktivitu měli.
Je to otázka, jak se k tomu postavíme.
Ty rozpočty jsou však neúprostné,
protože ten rozpočet je v současné době
víceméně stejný, jako se hrál v posledních letech Extraligy.
V posledních letech je potřeba říct,
že v poslední roky Extraligy, když se hrál Extraliga,
tak město Zlín tam dávalo 16 milionů,
a ne 10, to znamená, tam více se podíváte,
tam jste pořád, tam jste pořád,
je to i ten rozdíl, co tam nějakým způsobem ten rozdíl je.
platy hráčů logicky, tak jak zvyšuje vláda,
tady ta tarif je o 9% a podobně,
prostě víme, co se děje ve společnosti o inflaci,
tak logicky ty nároky nějak rostou.
A jediné, co já můžu říct si,
že když jsem děl rozpočty některých jiných prvolígových klubů,
tak jestli někdo debatuje, že se ve zně přeplácí hráči,
tak to můžu naprosto vyloučit,
protože jsou tu kluby,
které jsou například plus 20 milionů,
proti tomu to, co máme my.
Takže to jenom spíš,
zase ještě asi řekneme,
že tady naopak ta práce si myslím,
že je odváděná velice dobře,
že se to ještě dá nějakým způsobem podepisovat tak,
jak to dává nějak smysl.
Podobně jako v tom fotbale,
ti hráči, kteří dojdou s neadekvátním,
prostě potřebou nebo nějakou,
že prostě je nepodepíšou,
tak prostě odchází nám.
V tom spíš jenom,
ať si to asi řekneme,
to tam k tomu je.
Poprosím, pane Juráše.
Děkuju za slovo, pane primátore.
A my máme rádi Zlín.
Máme to v názvu Zlín 21.
Proto nutně musíme mít rádi
Zlínský hokej.
Vnímáme to jako naše rodinné dědictví Zlínské.
Myslím, že proč tu diskuzi vedeme,
spočívá právě v tom,
že ten hokej Zlínský máme všichni rádi.
Nemůžu podezírat ani náznakem paní Francou,
nebo pana Jandu,
nebo, nedej Bože, členy rady,
nebo vedení města Zlín,
že by jim nešlo o hokej.
Proto to v nás vyvolává takové emoce,
když se nám nedaří,
jsme naštvaní,
nechce se nám dotovávat peníze,
když se nám daří,
máme rozjásané davy lidí,
fandící na stadionu
a cítíme se být těmi zlíňáky.
Fajno.
Takže to je ten náš vstup.
Co dneska řešíme?
Já myslím, že řeknu tři takové body za nás,
ať to zazní.
Ten první je,
že my to vnímáme tak,
že řešíme aktuální situaci
financování hokeje.
Souhlasíme naprosto s tím,
že je možné,
řešit i budoucnost toho hokeje.
A s tím nutně souvisí i to,
zdá,
má všechno,
co se kolem toho hokeje motá,
to znamená včetně hokejové licence,
býti či nemá býti navedeno
do společnosti s ručením omezeným,
která v této chvíli
hraje tu druhou nejvýšší soutěž.
Ta diskuze by ale měla proběhnout,
to znamená,
má město míti hokej,
nemá míti hokej,
v jakém rozsahu tam má být zapojeno,
co má případně poskytovat zaplnění,
co naopak zaplnění poskytovat,
nemá.
Nemyslím si,
že tyto diskuze patří sem v této chvíli
a je vhodné je spojovat právě
s aktuální finanční situací hokeje.
Je to totiž otázka budoucnosti,
kterou potřebujeme dobře diskutovat.
Za druhé, utíkají nám drobné detaily
při té diskuzi, kterou tady dneska poslouchám,
tak já to jenom rychle povím,
bez nějakého záměru působit
nějakým způsobem mentorsky.
Přece jen ve spolku má město vliv
na obsazení generálních manažerů.
Bez jeho hlasů ho nejde ani povzvolit,
ale ani odvolat.
To znamená, město drží kontrolu
nad výkonou mocí.
Město má hlas, který neumožňuje
bez jeho souhlasu tu licenci
převést, využít, prodat.
Čili město je schopno si v tom prosazovat
tu svoji působnost podle libosti,
čili v zásadě je to na městě,
kam se to bude posouvat
a znovu říkám, je to za mě opravdu
otázka té budoucí diskuze,
jakým způsobem hodláme
naplňovat tu vizi toho klubu.
No a konec konců za třetí,
tady to ještě nezaznělo,
já jsem v pondělí byl na té diskuze také
a nechci řešit detaily,
jestli je to opravdu nebo investice,
to jsme si myslím pověděli.
Nicméně ten zvolený technický způsob řešení
poskytnutí nějakých peněz
formou peněžitého příplatku
do vlastního kapitálu
nám zachovává určitou míru elasticity.
To znamená, že pokud by hokej fungoval báječně,
dobře se mu dařilo díky tomu,
že bude hrát první pětce,
k tomu se ještě vrátím,
tak když ta ekonomika bude vycházet,
tak město může za určitých úvách
si ty peníze odebrat zpět.
No a v neposlední řadě,
já to tady ještě nezaznělo,
máme tady zástupce hokeje,
ne úplně to vrchlové vedení,
ale ten vyšší management bez pochyby ano.
Na té prezentaci byly dva závazky.
A i tady řeknu,
protože jsem je takto zavnímal.
Ten závazek číslo jedna říká,
my jsme to vybrali tak,
aby jsme hráli následující sezónu v TOP 4.
Tak já to tak veru,
že to tak bude,
pevně v to doufám a věřím.
A komentoval jsem to způsobem,
ale je to váš závazek,
takže buď s vámi nebo bez vás.
A druhá,
když nám ty peníze poskytnete,
budeme mít vyrovnané hospodaření
v následující sezóně.
Tak já to tak beru jako závazek.
Jestli tady budu,
a nestalo by se to,
tak budu tady pánům na té lavici vzoru připomínat,
že to zaznělo.
Děkuju.
To jsem já říkal všem, ať už je to generální manažer, spojitný manažer, nebo i trenér,
on to na tom ledě neodehraje, takže samozřejmě je to potřeba nějakým způsobem dobře poskládat,
ale vždycky to bude stát a padat na výkonu těch hráčů a tedy je potřeba jim vytvořit ty podmínky
a motivaci k tomu, aby hráli co nejlépe a byli, teď řeknu, rádi za to, že hrát za zlý,
a nějakým způsobem se to brali k srdci.
Co se týká vyrovnáného rozpočtu, nikdo si nepřeje nic jiného už několik mnoho let,
a já jenom připomenu možná ty poslední roky, ještě ji zpřed a nahledneme do té extraligy historicky,
tak generální partner v těch nejsilnějších letech dává tařka 20 milionů korun a město tehdy 16 k tomu,
a ten rozpočet nebyl o moc vyšší než je nyní, tak já jenom tím si říct, že jsme o plus 10 let
a bavíme se, že jak město a ten generál dává ty části nižší,
a ve výsledku vlastně čekáme něco podobné výsledky,
ale samozřejmě bez toho významného generálního partnera je logické,
nebo ne logické, ale bohužel ten stav, že se to sbírá po kouskách
a pak je ten prostě problém, že se začíná s nějakou predikcí, že se něco dožene
a když se to nedožene, tak to pak způsobí tento problém, který tady máme
a je potřeba znovu jenom zdůraznit, že to, co tady je dneska, je víceméně věc týkajícíce několika let.
Není to, protože se bavíme, že toto tady vzniklo poslední měsíc.
Ale je to tak. Tak poprosím pana Mitáčka.
Děkuji, pane primátore, za slovo. Kolegině kolegové, já jsem chtěl začít tím,
že navazují na diskuzi předcházející oplnění slivů a závazků mezi městem a ostatními.
A také si to moc přeji, já potvrduji slova pana Juráše, nejenže to tam bylo vyřečeno,
ty závazky, ale oni tam dokonce byly písemně představeny.
Chci poděkovat vedení radnice za to, že vůbec ten seminár zorganizovalo
v tom formátu, ve kterém proběhl. Velmi děkuju všem přítomením,
protože dlouho nepamatuju seminár, kde byl byl účastnout taková
zástupnost zastupitelů přítomných a tak dobrá, otevřená,
upřímná debata, dlouhá, která proběhla. A zároveň poděkování vedení klubu
nebo společnosti za představení a odkrytí všech čísel, které nám doteď
v ozovkách nebyly nikdy ukázány a nebyly přístupné. A potvrduji slova pana primátora
představy občanů, které vychází z nějakých pověr, pomluv,
se naprosto nepotkávají s realitou, která v té ekonomice hlavně
v odměňování je. Také považuji odměňování hráčů
a manažerů za běžné, standardní, dokonce bych někde řekl i průměrné.
Nicméně mě tam velmi zaujívala jedna věc a to byla otevřená diskuze,
co vlastně dál a které ty modely by mohly být vůbec ve hře.
Ať už s tou licencií nebo bez té licence. A jenom tohle to mi dává
jako dobrou naději pro mě osobně, že jsme ochotni tu cestu hledat,
otvíráme si k tomu tu diskuzi, což je nesmírně fajn,
a že přemýšlíme všichni nad tím, jaké jsou možnosti vůbec,
jak si s tím hokejem poradit s jedním společným cílem,
aby ten hokej tady zůstal a mohl dál tady fungovat. Děkuju.
Děkuju za ten příspěvek. Jak jsem řekl, já si myslím,
že o hroby to oddělilo. Dneska to hlasujeme něco, co je potřeba vyřešit.
A vedle toho, když se řeknu vedení města a obecně,
když se řeknu asi v rámci jakýchkoliv diskuzí,
my jsme opakovaně deklarovali, že prostě se toho podílu nedržíme.
A vzhledem k tomu, že tu diskuzi prostě vnímáme do té budoucnosti,
které jako potřebnou, tak prostě i proto jsme vlastně začali zjišťovat možnosti,
jestli vůbec někdo má nějakým způsobem zájem do toho,
kovo vstoupit nebo se na tom nějak podílet, proto byl vlastně vyhlášený,
nebudu říkat předeběžně tržní konzultace, je to vícemě průzkum trhu,
kdy v současné době my to vůbec nevážeme, jestli licenci má spolek nebo sročko,
je to prostě otázka toho, že potom nějakých dalších jednání my vůbec zjišťujeme,
jestli někdo má vůbec potenciální zájem se do toho začít podílet.
A významně podílet, není to otázka jako jednotek milionů,
že nám někdo dá garanci, že si svěříme 79% a dostane Andrá závazek,
že bude dávat do klubu 2 miliony ročně, to asi bychom se nedohodli.
Takže proto říkám, že se musíme bavit o významu a to jsou ty postupné otázky,
které tady dneska zaznívají, které do budoucna musíme řešit.
To znamená, bude tam někdo s námi nebo jsme na to zůstali sami v současné době.
A na základě toho se pak můžeme posunout dál.
To znamená, teď má to být zhruba měsíc, měsíc a půl otevřené tady ten průzkum.
Uvidíme, jestli se nám do toho někdo přihlásí, kdy my v současné době říkáme,
že kdokoliv o to má zájem, tak jakkoliv se do toho vstoupí,
jestli tam dá nějaký svůj model takový nebo jiný.
Pro nás je to zajímavé, abychom věděli, v jakých intenciích ten dální subjekt uvažuje,
ale zároveň potřeba vědět, jestli vůbec nějaký existuje.
Takže to je vlastně, proč my jsme tuto iniciativu udělali a uvidíme,
jak to nám vlastně přinese a na základě toho já beru, že se budeme bavit dál,
jak s tím do budoucna vlastně opravdu vůbec tady s tím rodinným stříbrem nachládat.
Poprosím pana Sáhu.
Bych se podíval do historie, jak se vlády a králové a jiní starali o ty skvělý věci,
například sportovní aktivity, nějaké ty lazarety, ale také o třeba univerzity.
A neexistoval případ, že by někdo založil třeba univerzitu nebo něco takového
a negarantoval trvalo ekonomické zabezpečení.
Třeba nejstarší švédská univerzita dostala devětset farem tomu zníku,
což oni pak třeba před stolety chápali jako těžko koulí na noze,
ale dneska je to biznis, ze kterého celá ta univerzita žije.
Takže univerzitní hokej, ano, ale já teď jenom chci říct,
že my se chováme pořád jak kdyby ještě nedospělé,
protože ten středověk už to řešit uměl a my to řešit neumíme.
Takže jenom a kdo je za to vysít? No ten majitel, to je město,
tak mají třeba sednout a vymyslet ten model, který zajistí trvalou udržitelnost, že?
A nakonec Evropa se vráci k tomu slovíčku udržitelnost,
i když z pohledu té logiky věcí udržitelnost je špatné slovo,
protože to znamená už neposun dopředu, tak jinými slovy,
když jsme na konstantní hranici, tak jdeme dolů, je to je první krok dolů.
Ale to udržitelné zachování těch aktivit, které město si vezme jako své vlastní to stříbro,
tak tomu je třeba věnovat pozornost a vymyslet ten model ekonomicky.
A to se omlouvám, takže to je všechno. Děkuji.
Dobrá, moc která děkuju všem, kteří přispěli do této diskuze.
A děkuji se nikdo další nehlásí, tak já bych vás chtěl poprosit,
že budeme hlasovat materiál číslo 27.
Pro 34, materiál číslo 27 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 28 týkající se rozpočtového opatření,
týkající se právě tohoto předchozího bodu.
To znamená, abychom ty finance, které jsme schválili v předchozím bodě,
mohli dát, tak musíme vytvořit rozpočtového opatření.
Jsou k tomu dotazy? Nejsou.
Takže prosím pojďme hlasovat o materiálu číslo 28.
Pro 35, materiál číslo 28 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 29 je vydání změny číslo 6 zemního plánu.
Vydání změny číslo 6 znamená, že dnešním dnem bychom potvrdili územní plán
tak, jak byl postupně projektantem a zapracován.
Zcela otevřeně víme, že k nám došly nějaké dopisy,
které rozporují některé změny.
Já za sebe říkám, že i zde bychom byli rádi,
kdybychom postupovali stejným systémem jako změny číslo 5,
to znamená schválili tento balík změn jako celek
a pokud je tam jakýkoliv problém, tak aby lidé využili svého práva,
který je rok od schválení zastupitelstva,
to znamená od dneška na další rok,
to znamená řekněme do 17.6.2027,
se můžou ke každé jednotlivé změně odvolat k soudu
a vlastně říct ty své důvody, proč si myslí, že to je špatně.
Důvodem je toho, že my z pozice zastupitelstva
jinak nemáme, máme jedinou možnost jinou,
a to je to, že vrátit celý ten územní plán přepracování
s nějakým zadáním, kdy to zadání samozřejmě neznamená,
že bude akceptováno daným projektantem.
Tam je potřeba říct si, že město jenom doporučuje,
nikoli přímo zadává nebo může rozhodnout.
Takže proto i já za sebe říkám, že v těchto případech
už je jednodušší to schvál jako celek,
a pokud má někdo k jednotlivým bodům z toho celého balíku problém,
ať si ho prostě řeší tou cestou, které zákon umožňují.
Poprosím paní Blahovou.
Dobré dopoledne, hlásím v tomto bodě střed zájmu.
Dobře, děkuji, poprosím pana Vančuru.
Děkuji, také střed zájmu a týká se i toho následujícího bodu,
po kterém budeme hlasovat, děkuji.
Ano, dobře, a poprosím pana Jandu.
Primátore, taky bych rád nahlásil střed zájmu, děkuji.
Dobrá, mozka, děkuji.
Níkdo se další do diskuze k tomuto bodu nehlásí,
takže střed zájmu máme nahlášeny a pojďme prosím hlasovat
o materiál číslo 29.
Pro 26, materiál číslo 29 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 30 je zrušení usnesení,
s tím, že se schovujeme jenom nové.
Celý celý materiál se týká posunu termínu příjemu
nebo akceptace žádostí, které se projeví ve změni číslo 7.
Je to z důvodu toho, že dnes my jsme plánovali,
že dneska na zastupitelstvu budeme schovat zadání změny číslo 7,
kdy vzhledem k procesním věcem jsme nakonec přistoupili k tomu,
že dneska budeme schovat pouze rozhodnutí o pořízení,
ale nebudeme tady mít hlasování o zadání.
Tím pádem jsme chtěli zase víc říct všem,
kteří ty žádosti ještě zase podávali dál s myšlenkou,
že to bude sice do osmičky, ale tím, že jsme posunuli ten termín,
tak jim chceme víc říct a posunujeme termín,
že ty žádosti, které přišly po 31. třetí a dojdou do 19.6.,
což je doznířka, tak budou ještě zapracovány právě do změny číslo 7.
Důvodem, proč 19.6. je ten, že naopak jsme zvažovali,
jestli to nejde do 15.6. zpětně,
protože jsme nechtěli zase se stát do té podoby,
že najednou tam přistane 20, 30, 40 žádostí úplně jako nových,
kdy pokud by se tohle stalo, tak vlastně bude velmi ohrožen
neli nereálná možnost schvální té zadání té změny v září.
Takže proto je ten termín teďka 19.6., abychom více méně akceptovali to,
co tam k dnešnímu dni už došlo a na co jsme relativně připraveni
a bereme, že po určitých dohodách například,
aby některé orgány nevyužili celou svou lhůcu 30 dnů,
ale něco kratší, tak jsme to schopni bezpečně nachystat na září
a v září pak schválit celou tu změnu a i s těmi věcmi,
které přijdou, přišli teďka později.
To znamená, přišla nám takové fairové řešení
a proto je to tady dneska takhle na stole.
K tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, tak prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 30.
Pro 33, materiál číslo 30 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 31 je právě to rozhodnutí o pořízení změny číslo 7,
to znamená, dneska jenom schválíme, že 7 chceme pořídit,
to nám umožní začít řešit výběrové řízení na budoucího projektanta,
to znamená začít ty věci připravovat, abychom nestratili řekněme ty dva měsíce prázdnin
a budeme na tom moci pracovat dál, vyhlásit veřejnou soutěž
a samotné zadání budeme tedy schvalovat v září, na zářivém zastupitelstvu.
Poprosím pana Vančuru.
Děkuju, střed zájmů, prosím.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Je někdo další? Do diskuze se někdo další nehlásí,
takže prosím pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 31.
Pro 32, materiál číslo 31 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 32 je již zmíněná novela obecně závazné vyhlášky,
kde se mění vlastně u akce Neuronight Opener,
takže nebude z noci z 6. na 7. 8., ale má být ze 7. na 8. 8.
To znamená, byla tam ani spíš administrativní chyba, kterou tímto rovnáme,
a akce bude moci takto proběhnout zpátka na sobotu.
Zatímco předtím to bylo ze čtvrtka na pátek, což by bylo horší, což by samozřejmě asi nedávalo smysl
z nočního klidu a že lidé se v pátek chodí normálně do práce z pravidla i přes prázdiny,
takže tady by to bylo asi, tady předpokládám, že na opravu byla administrativní chyba,
nejspíše nejspíše u nás, nechci řešit, jestli to bylo, že protože při podání si předpokládám,
že ten termín není páteční. Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí, prosím pojďme nosav materiál číslo 32.
Pro 36, materiál číslo 32 byl přijat.
Tímto jsme vyčerpali všechny body, které jsme dneska na programu hlasování
a já otvírám diskuzi po dnešním zastupitelstvu,
jestli to máte nějaké body. Poprosím paní Francovou.
Já teda slibuji, že se pokusím naposledy.
Já bych poprosila k tabulce, o které jsme se tady bavili,
protože se trošku pozměnila.
Jedná se právě o to rozpočtové opatření, které jsme dostali na vědomí,
kde je, jestli už jsme ji dohledali, nebo jestli to mám přečíst,
je to číslo 9, romeno 9Z 2007, tabulka číslo 2,
kde uvolňujeme 700 tisíc na modernizaci skateparku Bartoška,
teda přesunujeme z investic právě na uhradu publicity.
Já bych poprosila, protože vidím, že jste to tak nějak jako nečekali tento dotaz,
já bych poprosila, jestli byste mi k tomu napsali, o co se přesně jedná,
kdo tu publicitu bude zajišťovat, v jakém rozsahu,
jestli jsme to soutěžili klidně písemně, ať to tady teďka neřešíme.
Děkuju.
Určitě jo, tam není problém, jako tady přesně vím, o co se jedná,
já to řeknu hned potom, to víceméně si tomu sedneme,
nebo řekneme si, co a jak, my jsme vzali určité úpravy,
řešili jsme nějaké věci v rámci těch veřejných řízení,
to znamená, pak si k tomu dáme vědět, jak to bylo myšleno,
ten systém se vyvíjí, toto byly určité nějaké pilotní projekty,
a bude to do budoucna řešeno jinak, ale že si řekneme, proč to tam takhle je.
Poprosím pana Jandu.
Děkuji, pane primátore, já jsem chtěl poděkovat za opravu mostu na Vršavě,
kterou jsem urgoval, děkuji za to, že to proběhlo dokonce místo dvou dnů v jednom dnu,
takže konečně se z takového vlastně jediného krajského dřevěného mostu
asi můžu říct, stálo něco normálního, co se dalo přejít, přejet,
protože předtím to trošku připomínalo tankodrom,
takže chtěl jsem poděkovat za občany, chtěl jsem poděkovat za sportovci,
že se to podařilo, snad to nebudeme příště honit tak,
aby to bylo v takovém stavu tak dlouho, ale výsledek je výborný,
takže děkuji za to.
Dobrý, moc krát děkujem.
Nikdo další se poprosím, že pana Mitáčka.
Omlouvám se, pane primátor,
že jsem to vstoupil na poslední chvíli.
Jenom samozřejmě v souvislosti s otevřením
nového úseku dálnice 249 do Frištáku je jasné,
že veškerá navigace přivádějící lidi k zoo povede
tou zkratkou od koní ze zadu k hlavní bráně.
Poprosím jenom, máme nějaké informace nebo plán,
co s tou komunikací, jestli vůbec máme možnost do toho,
my jako město nějak vstoupit s návrhem na posilnění, rozšíření
nebo úpravu té komunikace alespoň dočasně,
tak aby zvládala ten nápor.
Dneska máme dokonce na stole materiály o rozvoji zoo,
kde ta ambice milion návštěvníků je fakt očekávaná, predikovaná,
tak pochopitelně je to téma, které, jak víte, opakovaně tady zvedám,
a teď mě to začíná trápit o to víc, protože vím,
co je to za komunikaci, každý den skoro tam jezdím
a každý den jsou tam nové čáry od barvy od policie po nějakém střetu.
Tak chci toto rizikové místo co nejrychleji eliminovat s vaší pomocí,
s pomocí kraje, samozřejmě možná i dalších účastníků,
ale toto já považuji za absolutní riziko při tom nájezdu
nebo rozjezdu návštěvníků zoo. Děkuju.
My jsme s krajem diskutovali už dva roky zpátky,
víc než dva roky zpátky jsme začali řešit přesně tady tento stav,
že se to chystá. To znamená, kraj postupně opravuje tam ty komunikace,
které jsou vlastně směrem manžů z Frištáků na Lukov a vlastně takto.
Řešili jsme také, že by bylo vhodné začít řešit tuto komunikaci,
která vlastně povede na zoo, protože z největší pravěpodobností se začne dít to,
že lidé sedou z dálnice a v současné chvíli nebudou pokračovat kolem Frištácké přehrady
a nebudou jezit tou standardní cestou, ale budou se vracet do Frištáku přes Frišták
a stama na zoo, to znamená povedou tou zadní cestou.
S krajem jsme o tom mluvili, probíhají tam určité přípravy s krajem a je to krajská cesta,
takže oni s ním počítají a uvidíme, jak rychle se jim podaří,
protože samozřejmě někam není to otázka, že bychom to otevřeli před půl rokem,
řešíme to už roky a kraj v tom to je, když to řeknu, vstřícný, aktivní,
jakým způsobem prostě to vnímá a chce prostě Sarme tam ty věci řešit,
ale tak, jak jsme se tu bavili, bohužel ty věci trvají,
ty přípravné práce netrvají v měsíce, bohužel.
Poprosím ještě pana Mitáčka.
Ano, děkuju, pane primátore. Děkuju za to, že to vnímáte,
nebo všichni, co tam bydlíme, žijeme, jezdíme, tak to víme denně.
Pochopitelně na kraji se o tom vedou diskuze a to řešení se hledá.
Já se chci vrátit ještě k nějakému tématu z minulosti v této oblasti
a to bylo téma na stole, které bylo přesunout hlavní bránu do jiných částí ZOO,
otevřít jiné nové parkovací plochy s tím spojené,
tak se chci zeptat, jestli v tomto je nějaký posun v tom návrhu
nebo se od něho úplně ustoupilo, případně ještě můj dávný návrh
vyřešit tu šílenou křižovatku před hlavním vstupem kruháčem. Děkuji.
Co se týká přesunu vstupu, to téma pořád existuje.
Na druhou stranu je to otázka právě teď i těch debat vlastně toho příjezdu z Frištáků
a vůbec teda reakce na to, protože posunovat to ještě zase dál,
tak je otázka, jestli je to to správné. To znamená, vyhodnocují se různé varianty
právě i ve spolupráci s krajem. Takže to téma bych jenom odpověděl,
že existuje a ještě toho řešení je. Co se týká křižovatky,
tam jsme s krajem jednali, ale zatím neúspěšně.
Jenom bych ještě možná vyopravil pro vás pro všechny jednu věc,
co já jsem to vždycky všude ve všech médiích říkal,
ale vzhledem k tomu, že jsem zaznamenal na sociálních sítích zase,
je používáno. Dále to, že kamiony budou jezít do Frištáku,
prosím vás, není tomu tak. Dálnice D49 do Frištáku je skloudová nad tím,
že je tam omezující, je tam značka do 12 tun.
Je to z důvodu toho, že v rámci celého řízení řesedo má vlastně povoleno
nebo má tam tento zákaz kamionů s tím, že povolení využívání dálnice D49
ty kamiony bude až ve chvíli, kdy tato dálnice povede do Lípy.
Tak jenom spíš, kdyby se vás někdo ptal, tak vlastně ten stav,
kdybyl doteď, když to řeknu do toho Lešova, když to bylo otevřené,
tak by měl zůstat dál. Takže jenom spíš, když se vás vybude ptát nebo někteří z vás něco šíříte
na sociálních sítích, tak jenom ať to víte, že to tak úplně není.
Moc vám děkuju, pane primátor, za tento dovětek, který je velmi důležitý
a sám jsem taky zaznamenal na sociálních sítích tyto náznaky debaty
a bylo by dobré toto možná i někde oficiálně víc tlačit i kolegové zastupitelky,
zastupitele, že opravdu ta obava z toho, že se naraz tady vytvoří kilometrové kolony
kamionu před Kauflandem od Frištáku je samozřejmě nesmysl.
To je opravdu hloupo za dezinformace.
Nehledě na to, že nemají kam v centrum města projet, prostě do podjezdu nikdo nevěde
a objíždě to kolem Čepkova nebo přes Jižní svahy, tak nevím, která navigace
a kdo tam jako možná balkánský kamion, možná ano, takže to zkusí,
ale nikdo příčetný tam ani kdy v životě nepojde. Takže děkuju za to,
tohle bylo velmi důležité a děkuju, že jste to i řekl.
Dobrá, děkuju. Poprosím ještě náměstka Michala Číška.
Já bych chtěl jenom doplnit, že ten zákaz kamionu nebo vozidl na 12 tun je tam
od prvopočátku, už v prvním vyjádření vlastně k EI.
Tak možná, když někam něco napíšete, tak si to zkuste uveřit
a třeba mi napsat. A já vám to rád sdělím. Děkuju.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Vzhledem tomu, že nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak já bych vám chtěl poděkovat za dnešní konstruktivní jednání.
Jsem za to velice rád a popřeval bych vám tímto pěkné prázdniny.
Pozval bych vás na městský festival Zlín žije.
Zároveň bych chtěl poděkovat filmovému festivalu za opravdu krásnou reprezentaci města Zlína.
Myslím si, že se tento ročník opravdu znova povedl.
Takže děkuji z tohoto místa panu Čestmíru Vančurovi jako prezidentovi i celému jeho týmu.
A věřím tomu, že ta spolupráce bude pokračovat i v dalších letech a bude to přinášet opět radost nás všech.
Takže se hlásí pan Vančura a já vás poprosím, jestli byste se mohl ještě utišit. Děkuji.
Omlouvám se, jestli jsem se pozdě přihlásil.
Jsem moc rádi, že festival dopadnul, jak dopadnul.
Myslím, že se daří precizovat práci nejenom s partnery, ale především s městem.
A doufám, že jste si to taky povšimli.
Takže moc děkujeme všem složkám, které se na tom podílali s městem.
Hodně lidí to zasáhlo. Stejně tak, jako hodně lidí ve Zlíně.
Takže sluší se, a rád to dělám, poděkovat i občanům za toleranci.
A samozřejmě vedení z města, kde plánujeme už i, jak bychom mohli spolupracovat do budoucna.
Takže ještě jednou moc děkujeme a zase doufám, že se spolu se všemi v příští roku vidíme.
Přejeme hezké prázdniny.
Taky moc krát děkuji a čeká nás také, že polovně srpna bar umreli.
Tak jenom, ať víte, snad už se ani na ně nezapomínám.
Dneska jsme o ní hlasovali mimochodem.
Takže moc krát děkuji své pěkné prázdniny a v září se uvidíme.